an SCP Foundation researcher sits at a
table inside of a standard containment
cell these are often dangerous places to
be especially when the SCP you're
supposed to be studying is one that you
can't see the researcher is taking notes
unsure of exactly what is going to
happen next he can hear the sounds of
knives scraping behind of Flesh sizzling
and Searing from high heat he braces
himself as a burst of heat hits the back
of his head as if a fireball has erupted
an object floats through the air and
settles in front of him on the table
it's a plate of food and it looks
delicious it may surprise you to learn
that there is no rule that the SCP
Foundation must deal exclusively with
violent and vicious creatures not every
SCP held in containment shares the same
malevolence and contempt for Humanity as
scp-682 or the world-ending threat posed
by the likes of
scp-2317 some perhaps not many but some
are benign and might even seem outwardly
friendly but you'd still be taking a
huge risk to assume that anything
contained by the SCP Foundation is
completely harmless such is the case
with
scp-5031 as per the foundation's
containment procedures this
quasi-humanoid meaning it appears to
have some vaguely human features is held
in an airtight cell that is regularly
checked by Foundation Personnel on a
bi-weekly basis
scp-5031 has no need for regular
nutrition or regular interactions from
staff the trick with scp-5031 is not
being eaten by it since though it
doesn't need food it does still hunt and
consume anything it encounters human or
otherwise
avoiding being eaten is hard enough with
creatures that can actually be seen But
like so many other creatures the
foundation keeps contained
scp-5031 has developed an almost perfect
defense mechanism
which is when observed it will literally
cease to exist
some might choose to refer to this as a
Quantum lock however it is worth noting
that Trace is left by scp-5031 still
remain observable when the creature has
temporarily disappeared for example
Trails of blood and scratch marks left
behind by scp-5031 still exist when the
SCP itself does not
naturally this makes both avoiding the
creature and capturing it using cameras
difficult however when scp-5031's
existence ceases it still casts a shadow
from this researchers have been able to
determine several of the creature's
physical traits
based on its silhouette it has been
deduced at scp-5031 levitates about half
a meter above ground level Sports in
abnormally small necklace head atop an
elongated torso approximately 1.9 meters
long
with three sets of spindly lower arms
that Branch outwards using these arms
and its Loosely hanging body
scp-5031 will lower itself to hunt any
human or animal that draws near to it
and uses the blade-like tail to cut up
food
perhaps the most interesting facet of
scp-5031 Beyond its defensive
capabilities and apparent physical
attributes for the series of nine tests
conducted by senior researcher Stanley
Huxtable appalled by the conditions that
the creature was being kept in Huxtable
took over the role of hcl's supervisor
for
scp-5031 having grown increasingly
frustrated and empathetic towards the
creature listening to its screams from
inside its iron containment unit
Huxtable devised a series of tests to
introduce scp-5031 to various different
stimuli as a way to better understand
the creature and hopefully keep it
contained in a way that didn't seem to
cause so much suffering it's worth
remembering that the SCP Foundation
makes its mission to be cold not cruel
in performing their duties to protect
normality
and many of the researchers and staff
are just as capable of having empathy
for creatures as you might for a stray
animal at a shelter
the first of huxtable's tests involved
installing speakers in scp-5031 cell
through which a variety of different
ambient and popular pieces of music were
played to see if they had any effect on
reducing the creature's stress by
judging scp-5031 stress levels based on
how much it screened when compared to
normal
Huxtable was able to determine how to
best use music to calm the creature
scp-5031 seemed to convey higher levels
of stress when listening to morning
Forest deep Grotto and seaside Paradise
Ambience as well as the best of late 60s
British rock band Jethro Tull however
the best of Mozart Enya kiss and Ben
Folds produce dramatically different
results decreasing scp-5031's apparent
stress following this test senior
researcher Huxtable compiled a playlist
featuring
scp-5031's favorite music over time the
stress reducing effects of Music on
scp-5031 seemed to decrease
but keeping the playlist on shuffle
seemed to keep the creature consistently
calmer than it had been previously
the next test involved introducing
inanimate objects into
scp-5031's enclosure to monitor its
reactions and how its stress levels were
affected when a softball was thrown into
the enclosure
scp-5031 immediately sliced the ball in
two with its tail in one swift motion a
similar result occurred when researchers
threw the creature of basketball which
was quickly punctured and sliced open by
scp-5031's tail its stress levels first
seemed to diminish when the creature was
offered a bowling ball which it rolled
around the enclosure and then later
knocked it against a second volleyball
however when one of the balls chipped
rendering it unable to roll properly
scp-5031 stress increased dramatically
until a replacement was offered
researcher Huxtable noted that scp-5031
seemed to possess a similar level of
motor skills to an average human toddler
with similarly explosive emotional
reactions to match
next when given the choice between two
food sources at opposite ends of its
enclosure
scp-5031 seemed to gravitate towards
higher quality food most notably favored
cooked rotisserie chickens over animal
carcasses
it even chose this option over a live
chicken using its tail to cut its food
into more manageable bite-sized portions
rather than ripping its meat with its
hands or teeth like many of its fellow
scps
researcher Huxtable recorded these
findings and highlighted that even
though scp-5031 didn't need to eat in
order to survive
providing the creature with food of a
better quality marginally reduced its
stress
senior researcher Huxtable next
attempted to test
scp-5031's coexistence with other living
subjects
each time making sure that the creature
had been adequately fed to avoid any
unseemly incidents
first a live chicken was introduced
scp-5031 rolled its bowling ball at high
speed towards the chicken increasing
both its and the chicken's stress levels
and inadvertently killing the chicken in
the process
when a second chicken was introduced
scp-5031 gently rolled a basketball
towards it but ceased any further
engagement after the chicken squawked
from being hit by the ball next to be
introduced into the enclosure was a
blindfolded d-class staff member who was
instructed to sit down and roll the
basketball towards
scp-5031 after doing so for several
minutes the creature began to approach
the d-class subject who was instructed
to remove their blindfold to Cease the
creature's existence and prevent any
potentially deadly incidents finally
researcher Huxtable had another class D
engage in a game of catch with scp-5031
while facing away from the creature
this test proceeded successfully and
Senior researcher Huxtable remarked how
scp-5031's motor skills were improving
albeit gradually and with some gentle
encouragement through huxtable's tests
the creature was learning
the next test focused on teaching
scp-5031 linguistic symbols utilized LCD
displays and buttons connected to a food
dispenser One display showed an image of
a rock and the other an image of a
rotisserie chicken after some brief
probing
scp-5031 was quickly able to understand
that pressing the button under the
correct display would dispense a
rotisserie chicken for it to eat the
creature was later able to adapt when
the following day the screen displays
and materials dispensed were swapped and
then later set to swap at random
intervals when additional Rock
dispensing stations were introduced this
time displaying the word rock as opposed
to an image
scp-5031 was able to determine which
station dispensed chicken through a
process of elimination whenever the
functions and displays were swapped
scp-5031 would find whichever displayed
the word chicken to receive its food the
Final Phase of this test presented
scp-5031 with a single station
displaying the word chicken but with a
button that would remain in active
unless the creature spelled out the same
word with a collection of lettered
blocks it was provided with after some
initial confusion and frustrations as to
why the button would not dispense food
when pressed
scp-5031 was able to assemble the word
correctly not only activating the button
and dispensing food but proving to
researcher Huxtable that the creature
was capable of learning language
Huxtable continued to test the creature
encouraging it to spell words using
lettered blocks as a method of
communicating by increasing scp-5031's
vocabulary and the amount of human
interaction it received senior
researcher Huxtable observed that
scp-5031 was gradually learning to sing
albeit non-verbally as well as to juggle
with its six hands and was even
communicating its food preferences and
Dish pairings
later another class D
d52125 was introduced to scp-5031's
enclosure to Aid and further testing
through
d-52125's instructions the creature
quickly learned to draw using crayons
and created artworks depicting itself
its Newfound friend
d-52125 researcher Huxtable a cat and a
rotisserie chicken
scp-5031's new creative side didn't stop
there though as the creature quickly
learned to play chopsticks in only two
days once a piano was introduced into
the enclosure
scp-5031 even managed to start creating
its own original admittedly crude
compositions next a spice rack was
placed inside the creature's cell and
d-52125 demonstrated how to season meat
this proved to be
scp-5031's new favorite hobby as it
spent the next three days experimenting
with different combinations of foods and
spices using its letter blocks to
request more more garlic powder
interestingly the creature only created
artwork or music when d-52125 was
present but seemed to thoroughly enjoy
its experimentation with food when left
alone
following this development senior
researcher Huxtable devised a new test
for scp-5031 providing the creature with
cooking utensils and using
d-52125 to demonstrate 5031 was shown
how to prepare a variety of different
dishes from hamburgers and Tacos to
Mongolian beef steak clam chowder and
profiteroles in addition to a small
peanut allergy this eighth test revealed
scp-5031 to be a phenomenal chef
possessing culinary skills far beyond
the average person the creature quickly
and enthusiastically embraced its
Newfound talents concocting its very own
brand new recipes with d-52125 even
volunteering to be the first to taste
test 50 31's dishes it was shortly after
this test that scp-5031 spoke its very
first word
and it should come as no surprise that
the word was solved naturally senior
researcher Huxtable was very proud of
the progress the creature had made with
its development the final test almost
seemed to be what the creature was born
for over the course of two months
scp-5031 was tasked with creating a full
three-course meal which would then be
served to Foundation staff for
Thanksgiving
scp-5031 not only Rose to the task but
exceeded all of researcher huxtable's
expectations creating a meal that even
Gordon Ramsay would be hard-pressed to
find fault with
the creature created a first course
consisting of sweet potato miso soup
seasoned with turmeric next came a
beautiful duck calm fee blazed
luxuriously with apple cider and topped
generously with sweet cranberry compote
paired with a side of butternut squash
gnocchi and served on a bed of kales
seasoned with truffle salt the grand
finale of the Exquisite meal was a spice
cassava pie for dessert complimented
with the finest French vanilla ice cream
and a maple hazelnut syrup
an scp-5031 didn't stop there the
creature also debuted one of its
original musical compositions to
complement the decadent meal it had
created as the staff enjoyed the food
scp-5031 performed live from its
enclosure the deeply moving piano
concerto for six hands to an
overwhelmingly positive response from
not only senior researcher Huxtable but
the entire Foundation staff as a fitting
end to the creature's tail Huxtable
reported that during the Thanksgiving
banquet it had created
scp-5031 stress levels reduced entirely
new Kinder containment measures that
would keep 5031 safer but also far more
contented were submitted for approval
perhaps some of you may find it
refreshing to learn that scp-5031 isn't
simply just another malicious malevolent
monster that the foundation has to keep
under lock and key for the safety of the
world
instead scp-5031 is a gentle if a little
frightening at first creature that just
requires careful and considered guidance
instead of a cold iron cage and
around-the-clock arm guards through
testing senior researcher Stanley
Huxtable and his fellow Foundation staff
were not only able to help the creature
develop but also found what makes it
tick and not just for the purposes of
containing it instead it is hoped that
scp-5031's creativity and Flair for
culinary and musical masterpieces can
continue to thrive and grow under the
proud watch of researcher Huxtable a
veteran worker of the SCP Foundation
sits at his terminal performing one of
the most critical tasks in the entire
organization creating a file for an as
yet undescribed SCP but there's
something terribly wrong his eyes are
glazed over his mouth hangs open is this
a zombie or a trained Foundation
researcher
what is going on like any large
International Organization it takes more
than just the exciting action-filled
jobs to keep the wheels turning at the
SCP Foundation sure the head researchers
guards mobile task force soldiers and
members of the o5 command get all the
praise but a legion of number crunchers
cleaners and paper pushers are equally
important one such person was archivist
Walter Bainbridge who had been tasked
with digitizing some of the older
records that the foundation had on file
it was when he was innocently recording
the details on
scp-050-060 that he first came under the
strange and startling effects of
scp-055 but the most peculiar part as
with all incidents of
scp-055's anomalous effects taking hold
is that Walter had no idea any of it was
happening in this new digitized filing
system he first took note of scp-053
Euclid class also known as the young
girl this anomaly was a seemingly normal
human female child who provoked
homicidal Insanity in those directly
exposed to her then scp-054 safe class
a non-aggressive humanoid female made
entirely of as well as biologically and
chemically identical to regular Spring
Water next
scp-056 Euclid Class A being that
changes form to suit its environment but
only when all observers lose focus of it
and then
scp-057 safe class an underground
chamber that crushes the humans who walk
Within it was at this point that Walter
received a concerned message from one of
his superiors at site 19 Mr Kovach the
message praised the thorough
digitization of the other anomalies
records but was confused about why
Walter had left out any mention of
scp-055 immediately Walter was
embarrassed how could he have forgotten
scp-055 that iconic anomaly known for
well he couldn't quite say off the top
of his head but he'd be sure to look
into it a quick trip to the site-19
archive showed him that there was
actually quite a hefty file on the
nature of
scp-055 which must have been the result
of a huge number of studies what struck
him as strange was that all the files
were filled out in pen rather than being
typed up like a traditional file the
majority of these nodes were written in
shorthand too as though they were
frantically taken during the tests
themselves on extremely short notice
there weren't even any redactions Walter
made a mental note of what he had seen
put the file back in its proper place
and headed back to his computer terminal
however after riding in an almost
trance-like stay he looked back on his
work to see that he had written an entry
on
scp-058 a giant evil bovine heart with
insect legs and a scorpion Stinger
strange he thought that's when Walter
got a call from Mr Kovach on his
foundation issue phone and he didn't
sound happy he'd given Walter direct
instructions to go back and digitize the
files on zero five five and instead he'd
been working on zero five a what was the
meaning of This Walter was typically an
extremely loyal and diligent employee
but the verbal barrage from his
supervisor had him considering talking
back just this once and hoping it didn't
get him demoted to d-class and thrown
into 682's Acid Bath for playtime Walter
Galt picked up some courage and
interrupted Mr kovach's rant to ask if
he had any idea what scp-055 actually
was the line went silent for a moment
then his supervisor spoke again this
time with less confidence of course I
can tell you about
scp-055 it's a classic one of the first
hundred how could you forget it's uh or
yeah you know it's I think it's the one
with um
another long pause as Mr Kovach seemed
to search for the words but instead just
trailed off into silence knowing that
some of the anomalies on file were
dangerous mimetic hazards Walter was
worried for a moment that he may have
accidentally killed his boss by getting
him to think too hard about
scp-055 he asked if Mr Kovach was okay
and finally got a reply
I'm sorry I seem to have zoned out for a
second there what were we talking about
again
but this time it was Walter who couldn't
answer he had no idea at all what the
two of them were discussing just moments
ago he felt disoriented and kind of sick
like they'd taken some low level
amnestics Mr Kovach told Walter to get
back to his filing duties and they'd
speak later Walter then checked the
messages he'd received from Mr Kovach
earlier and there it was plain as day
you missed zero five five go back and
digitize that before proceeding Mr K but
Walter had never even heard of an
scp-055 if such an anomaly even existed
what was going on here in that moment
Walter realized he was dealing with
something much Stranger Than Just a
standard digitization job after all how
could he properly complete his duties of
scp-055 seemed to be impossible to speak
right or even think about unless you
were directly observing it at that
moment Walter had to know and ask around
the entirety of site 19 to find the
answers if he had to
sadly for Walter he was about to embark
on a much more challenging task than he
could have ever imagined to paraphrase a
supposed quote from Socrates all I know
is that I know nothing and that's also
about the extent of the knowledge we
have on
scp-055 also known as the anti-mean and
the self-keeping secret what does it
look like when and how was it obtained
by the foundation what are its anomalous
abilities the this thing dangerous we
may never know because the only
anomalous ability of scp-055 that we're
aware of is the fact that nobody is
capable of retaining any information
about it it's crucial to note that
whatever 055 is it isn't invisible or
Indescribable Foundation Personnel are
perfectly capable of entering its
containment chamber and observing it
without incident but mere minutes after
leaving the chamber any memories of the
particulars of 055 seem to spontaneously
erase themselves
hence the self-keeping secret but this
didn't deter Walter perhaps his greatest
Advantage was that he didn't know enough
about the thing he was investigating to
know how futile his mission was he
wanted to know the unknowable and a
pesky issue like impossibility wouldn't
stop him he'd get to whoever he needed
to at site 19 to get the answers he
needed of course most people had no
knowledge of the mysterious anomaly the
common response he got back from his
colleagues was zero five five do we even
have a zero five five well the
realization of sudden memory loss or the
realization of 055's existence has been
known to cause momentary stress there
are no known long-term physical or
mental effects from zero five five's
anomalous abilities it's a fleeting idea
in its purest form like forgetting why
you walked into a room 055 could be the
most harmless object on the foundation's
roster or the most deadly either way we
just don't know
at times Walter worried he was going
insane zero five five and everything
related to it was gaslighting him was
zero five five even real the one thing
that proved to him that 055 must have
existed is that its containment chamber
existed
according to the official records kept
by the foundation on the site-19
containment facilities
zero five five is kept in a five by five
by 2.5 meter Square Room constructed of
50-foot thick cement with a faraday cage
surrounding the cement walls the report
continues that access is via a heavy
containment door measuring 2 by 2.5
meters constructed on bearings to ensure
door closes and locks automatically
unless held open deliberately
055 cell is one of the few to have no
posted security guards and any Personnel
working on other scps in the area are
ordered to remain at least 50 feet from
the geometric Center of zero five five
cell
where the anomaly itself is capped when
he tried to explore further why the cell
was constructed in this manner he found
that surprise surprise nobody knew
055 was an anomaly whose containment
requirements were so mysterious that it
automatically netted itself a ketter
class designation after all how can you
properly contain something you can't
even hope to comprehend there were
plenty of rumors about the true nature
of 055
some of the more conspiratorial Minds at
site 19 theorized that 055 was actually
an autonomous or remotely controlled spy
inserted into the site to observe
Foundation operations or even Humanity
as a whole if you're on the more
paranoid end of the psychological
Spectrum this Theory makes total sense
an anomaly that's physically impossible
to remember even when writings and
pictures on the subject exist would be a
perfect spy however this was all
ultimately little more than speculation
Walter was barely any further along than
when he started there were multiple
points in his investigations where
Walter seriously considered giving up on
until finally he had a major
breakthrough Dr Bartholomew Hughes and
Dr John marichek were two scientists
that had performed extensive research
into zero five five and who Walter hoped
might have the answers he sought about
the self-keeping secret these scientists
were the first to discover the
anti-memetic nature of 055 performing
numerous tests on d-class Personnel to
see if it was possible to create
feasible written records sketches or any
other records or Impressions that could
bypass its anomalous effects the
disorienting memory ruining effects of
055 also extend to any materials
concerning 055 it seems to be a truly
uncrackable code but Dr Hughes may have
finally found some cracks in the armor
for starters the fact that we're able to
remember that zero five five is an
anti-memetic is an ironic exception to
its anti-memetic qualities this
Revelation also inspired another
realization from Dr Hughes
would it be possible to discover more
about zero five five from the process of
deduction rather than the typical
induction in other words could they
possibly learn about zero five five by
figuring out all the things it isn't
rather than what it is Dr marichek
designed an experiment with Dr Hughes to
explore this Theory they designed the
experiment around a simple question is
055 not spherical in designing the
question to specifically find out what
055 isn't they hope to subvert the
anomaly's anti-memetic powers Walter was
fascinated by this potential method of
getting answers marichek and Hughes
found that while the questioning process
for those exposed was often arduous and
frustrating
they could now definitely say that 055
is not a sphere it is theoretically
possible to discover the true nature of
055 by an almost endless barrage of
deductive questions though whether
command would authorize the resources
for such extensive testing is still an
open question Walter and his desperation
begged marichek and Hughes for clearance
to view zero five five himself the
Curiosity had become too great during a
search to just walk away with the single
fact that 055 was in spherical he needed
to see this thing and after several
weeks of filling out forms and cutting
red tape his wish was finally granted
Walter Bainbridge was allowed a private
audience with
scp-055 the subject of his month's long
Obsession Outsiders observe that Walter
spent just over an hour in the
containment chamber taking photos
drawing sketches writing down notes
recording audio logs and reciting memory
mnemonics he was pulling out every stop
to counteract the anti-memetic effects
of the self-keeping secret he was
adamant that he would not be defeated by
his non-spherical Nemesis not after all
this time and effort once his time in
the 055 containment chamber was over he
retired back to his office to finally
digitize his exhaustive findings so that
his supervisor Mr Kovach would finally
get off his back Walter smiled took a
deep breath and began to type
scp-059 ketter class this anomaly is a
radioactive mineral that emits a unique
radiation known as Delta radiation
exposure to this radiation has caused
strange fungal growth on the infected
wait what was this supposed to be about
again oh well it couldn't have been that
important does the black moon howl no
not yet see the boy he was born in a
time before names there weren't enough
humans around to need them back then he
was one of a handful occupying a Coastal
Village using a tongue long since
instead they eked out a simple life
hunting Gathering fishing the only thing
on most of their minds was surviving to
see the next sunrise yes a simple life
free of complications until the hermit
appeared the boy would remember this man
for eternity Haggard and thin skin
weathered by time and pain a man that
emaciated walking with a long gnarled
cane that honestly looked healthier than
he did shouldn't be alive even the boy
who had scarcely seen beyond the bounds
of his village knew that the hermit was
unnatural an aberration an anomaly he
walked into the center of the village
sat down on a large Stone and waited
nobody dared ask his business nor what
the hermit waited for then a few days
later the black moon howled the boys saw
The Village's youngest Hunter freeze one
evening while out on a walk not simply
stand still but freeze then for an
instant he became solid black a coal
statue and as soon as he'd changed he
was gone obliterated not a trace of him
remained such is the power of the black
moon it can make any conscious being
disappear in an instant turn black then
wiped from our plane of existence never
to be seen again its choice of victims
seemed at each instance to be utterly
random but it would come for all who
lived eventually this is known to some
as the howling of the black moon later
that same night the boy found himself
talking to the hermit who asked with
small frantic eyes what he had seen when
the boy told him he let out a deep
rattling sigh the boy curious asked him
if he knew about the nightmare he'd just
witnessed The Hermit looked up he'd been
the first one in the hermit's Millennia
of pursuit that had ever asked in that
moment he knew that he had found his
successor in the hunt for the death of
Ages The Hermit told the boy it went by
many names the great finale The Pale
King but most common of all was the
black moon The Entity existed Beyond the
Veil of our reality a creature of pure
energy though nobody could really be
sure of its true nature The Hermit had
been tracking it learning about it and
trying to destroy it for thousands of
years and yet it only took him four
pathetic minutes to tell the boy
everything he knew the boy knowing still
that something about the hermit was
unnatural asked how he came to be in
this position The Hermit told the boy he
was the counterbalance a kind of Chosen
One dust into face and perhaps even
defeat the black moon someday the
counterbalance receives a number of
truly extraordinary gifts for inheriting
the responsibility
eternal life
eternal youth near physical immortality
but they will be haunted by their
purpose doomed to watch everyone they
love die around them as they continue to
hunt their only true equal and opposite
the black moon itself The Hermit in his
own eyes had failed at its Duty he had
grown weary and now he needed to pass
the duty of counterbalance onto another
that other would be the boy he felt a
sudden and profound change along with
the knowledge that nothing would ever be
the same again he was no longer just the
boy now he was the counterbalance he
watched The Hermit give him a slight
knot of respect and then crumble into
dust before his eyes the boy the
counterbalance looked up at the sky and
saw the Stars twinkling so bright and so
beautiful little did he know his battle
with the black moon would Outlast every
single one of them does the black moon
howl not without blood the boy grew into
a man as his village aged and then died
around him decades passed then centuries
then Millennia tens of thousands of
years watching Humanity develop and grow
around him as he continued his pursuit
of that one elusive foe as science and
diagnostic technology gained ground
absorbing and then evolving beyond all
the old superstitions the counterbalance
gained a better understanding of the
black moon though even then it still
remained essentially a stranger The
Entity was entropic a being of pure
Randomness and Chaos without consistent
form it didn't exist in our universe but
it could exercise its influence here
with so-called obliteration events much
like the horrible fate that befell the
young hunter from the village but that
was only the proverbial tip of the
iceberg the counterbalance tracked and
noted obliteration events they were
exceedingly rare at first something that
occurred once every thousand years or so
like a terrible curse but he couldn't
help but notice a concerning Trend
emerging it started happening once a
century then once a decade he could feel
the terrible future stretching out in
front of him how over their shared
eternity the black moon would gain more
and more ground would there come a day
where it took someone once a year once a
month a week a day an hour a minute a
second he'd spell the end of all
conscious life life a total victory for
the black moon the end of the universe
the death of Ages a complete existential
obliteration he was swept up in a
sobering realization he couldn't win
this fight alone however while his hunt
for the black moon had been largely
fruitless the counterbalance had
discovered many other things along the
way strange creatures objects with
extraordinary powers and events that
couldn't be explained with rational
science perhaps something about these
Oddities
these anomalies would hold the key to
defeating his Timeless enemy and it
hadn't just been these objects entities
and events he'd also discovered some
truly exceptional people on his travels
minds and skills that rivaled even his
own despite his age perhaps they would
be the ones to help him win with the 13
most brilliant and trusted people the
counterbalance ever met he decided to
form a council and from this Council
they forged and directed an organization
dedicated to understanding and
counteracting the strange in all its
forms with the secret hope that their
search Into Darkness would yield the
answer to the black moons downfall he
called it the SCP Foundation they would
secure the anomalous contain it and
protect all of humanity from its
influence the counterbalance also took
on a new title The Fitting of his new
role the administrator and even the
black moon itself was given a moniker in
hopes of robbing it of some of its
frightening power
scp-001 does the black moon howl only at
the blind the year was now 1987. the SCP
Foundation had been operating for over a
century and thanks to their secret
possession of anomalous wisdom and
Technology their own advancement was
thousands of years ahead of the rest of
humanity while there's still wasn't a
silver bullet solution to the black moon
and its deadly howls were becoming all
the more frequent as the decades went on
the foundation did have some irons in
the fire to combat it their ability to
gather Intel on both the entity itself
and its obliteration events had improved
considerably thanks to their new Global
Information Network their top Minds were
also working on a highly classified
device known as the singular conceptual
bunker which may one day come in handy
for combating the extra dimensional
entity directly but the most valuable
piece of information they ever gathered
about the black moon was this it
couldn't howl when it was being watched
the very Act of engaged observation
defend it the problem is How Can You
observe something that doesn't
technically exist inside your own
reality in order to pull this off the
foundation would need to get extremely
creative thankfully Creative Solutions
to strange problems are the foundation
special T Flash Forward to 1993 enter Dr
Moto a brilliant young scientist and
conceptual engineer working for the SCP
Foundation with the administrator's
consultation he started the key project
an arm of the wider project Oro masades
the umbrella Initiative for using
modified anomalous objects in the battle
against the black moon the goal of the
key project was relatively simple if
people couldn't observe the black moon
directly then the foundation could make
proxies of the black moon that could be
observed almost like a kind of voodoo
doll these new anomalies would only need
to satisfy three criteria the inability
to operate when being observed a
hostility to conscious life and the
ability to end conscious life of their
own volition when not being observed
through conceptual engineering a link
theoretically could be forged between
these objects and the black moon
allowing observation of them to stop the
obliteration events however despite
being a good idea in theory Dr Moto's
efforts were marred with errors and
tragedies one object wasn't deadly
enough simply appearing behind people in
a threatening pose when they weren't
looking another one killed purely
through collateral damage a giant
sculpture of a human head that
immediately attempted to escape by
barging through site-01 the center for
anti-black Moon operations and killing
19 people in the process another one of
Moto's objects a huge black sphere
simply immediately exploded killing 12
people and in the most horrific misstep
of all one of Moto's objects caused a
mass death event in a nearby hotel where
142 people were spontaneously
incinerated when the object a series of
interlocking stalactites and stalagmites
were left unobserved for 0.2 seconds
almost all of Moto's objects were
terminated in the aftermath either being
too useless or too dangerous to keep
around the young scientists felt a deep
shame but forged on he may made one
truly brilliant creation that satisfied
all the criteria a sculpture incapable
of moving while being watched but would
snap the neck of the nearest conscious
entity if it left unobserved for even a
fraction of a second its relatively
minimal killing left it easy to contain
without causing Mass deaths and despite
all the other deaths that had sadly
occurred during the key project Dr Moto
believed that the lives saved in the
long run by stopping the black Moon's
howls would justify the sacrifice the
problem is the key project didn't stop
anything not long after this there was
the first recorded double obliteration
event in Rome where a young tourist
couple had both been obliterated
simultaneously all the deaths in the key
project had been for nothing the black
moon was only getting more powerful the
shame in the guilt was too much for Dr
Moto he left a note in his office
Reading we've been looking at nothing
I'm sorry administrator I failed you sir
MO corpse was later found in the
sculpture's temporary containment
chamber his neck snapped the key project
was in summary shut down and its one
surviving creation transported to site
19 in late 1993 where it was designated
as
SCP-173 another painful failure for the
administrator back to the drawing board
once more does the black moon howl not
while the stars shine Millennia
stretched on almost everyone died except
the administrator thanks to his gift or
perhaps curse as the counterbalance to
the black moon science marched on the
SCP Foundation marched on but all this
progress all this power was nothing
against the incomprehensible influence
of
scp-001 the black moon was howling more
frequently than ever all the way up to
the year 3156 when the foundation
launched the seek project under the
support of project oromastes has more
and more people were wiped out in
frequent obliteration events the
administrator became painfully aware
that perhaps the answers to the black
moon problem wouldn't be found on Earth
using state-of-the-art technology With a
Little Help from the anomalous the SCP
Foundation began work on an autonomous
space-faring vessel that could search
the stars for the key to the black
Moon's destruction it was an
awe-inspiring creation a huge craft
powered by artificial intelligence with
a universal translator cryogenic units
and hundreds of autonomous drones to
perform more targeted searches Zeke was
waved off into the unforgiving depths of
space the administrator could only hope
that it would come back with worthwhile
answers the first of the three notable
planets seek derived on was one
theoretically capable of supporting
human life except for its brutal and
constant blizzards and snowstorms when
sikh's drones were deployed they did
discover signs of civilization based
around sentient spherical creature
teachers but no signs of actual life
remained records and statues found
across the planet seem to indicate that
the black moon was responsible for the
destruction of the planet's civilization
causing so many obliteration events that
the remaining survivors went mad from
the fear and stress leading to mass
death in the ensuing chaos the next
planet was discovered centuries later in
the year 3499 while this planet could
also theoretically support human life it
suffered from frequent volcanic
eruptions that rendered much of its
surface a flaming Mass however there
were still the dormant ruins of a once
Advanced civilization of conscious
beings much like the prior Planet they'd
been driven extinct by Black Moon
obliteration events a century before the
Sikh even arrived unlike the last planet
however it seems that they accepted
their fate and went gently into the
night the planet was now overrun by
billions of armored bat-like creatures
that operated on pure Instinct and thus
were not considered conscious just
enough to be obliterated the final
planet was reached in 3764 and was the
most fruitful of the three discoveries
this planet was hyper Advanced fully
urbanized and covered in sprawling mega
cities with records and Technology over
a thousand years ahead of Earth before
the black moon killed almost all of them
there were species of humanoid
telepathic fungi and that developed an
awareness of the black Moon's existence
that was on par with that of humanities
they even had their own equivalent of
the SCP Foundation actively working on
countermeasures and most amazingly of
all seek found one surviving member of
this species on the planet cryogenically
frozen The graft was immediately
instructed to collect the Survivor and
return home for interrogation the
administrator Was preparing for what
could be the most important conversation
since he met the hermit all those
thousands of years ago does the black
moon howl only when waning when the
surviving creature codenamed saged was
returned to Earth the administrator was
eager to finally speak with it like the
rest of its now extinct species Sage
spoke through powerful telepathic mind
waves which only the administrator
thanks to his counterbalance abilities
was able to receive at close range
without being harmed incidentally it
wasn't long until the very fact of the
administrator's nature as a
counterbalance came up in the mental
conversation Sage could tell just by
being in his presence they discovered a
number of vital truths over their brief
time communicating that Sage's survival
had been pure luck for starters the
black moon is still very much capable of
obliterating conscious beings in an
unconscious State the administrator also
learned that he was merely the latest in
an extremely long line of
counterbalances across time space and
species though everyone but him had
waved this Duty passed it on Sage had
one question to ask the administrator in
turn what is SCB
the singular conceptual bunker being
worked on and perfected for thousands of
years by now by the foundation's top
scientists and conceptual Engineers the
administrator replied Victory but it
will take a very very long time
specifically so long that he would see
the stars go out around him one by one
shocked saged asked him what good
victory would do him then rather than
say it aloud he replied with a thought
Sage paused and said I see how
Blasphemous of you hopefully it works
after this the administrator proceeded
to the singular conceptual bunker and
entered it leaving instructions for the
foundation to be run by a newly formed
o5 Council in his indefinite absence
thousands of years later in the year
5011 Sage spoke one more time repeating
the words hopefully hopefully before
turning solid black and disappearing the
black moon had claimed one more victim
but billions more had gone in the
interim the administrator had no more
answers to give at least no more answers
that anyone but him would understand he
was inside the singular conceptual
bunker now loaded into a device known as
Tome an experimental Memorial module
meant to pick up and record all the last
messages of every dying civilization
Across the Universe when the time
finally came all he could do was wait
and wait was exactly what we did does
the black moon howl yes yes it does
years pass too many to count it's a time
after names now and Tome sits in the
very center drinking in the end of the
universe the last of all the human
colonies Across the Universe were
obliterated by the Black Moon back in
the year 73-29 so so so so long ago but
some of the final messages of fear panic
and distress still echoed around in the
administ Trader's mind hello is there
anyone here
we require assistance there's it's it's
taking people every day we need help
there's barely anyone left we need help
hello hello cabal zero nine four three
we have abandoned the false flesh we
have abandoned the false flesh the
shepherd's crook broke beneath my knee
Cabo zero nine four three come on zero
nine four three forgive us forgive us
we're going to leave this
so dark outside now it's blotted out the
sun it's I have to go now respond First
Convenience emergency
situation developing require additional
resources I thought your fault our fault
my fault your fault our fault my fault
your fault remember now rip I pray now
and a small child the last on Earth
simply asking hello into an indifferent
microphone but the administrator had to
wait as the singular conceptual bunker
became the solitary conceptual bunker he
was the last conscious being in the
universe and still he needed to wait as
the Stars went dark outside only when
there was nothing outside but black was
it finally time for the counterbalances
long game to play off there was nothing
left of our universe the only thing here
was the SCB and the black moon itself
with everything else gone the black moon
only had one conscious being left to
obliterate it opened the door to the
solitary conceptual bunker and stepped
inside this this doesn't make sense how
can the black moon an entity beyond our
Dimension Beyond physical form take a
step good question the same question
incidentally that was going through the
black Moon's mind as it entered the
bunker it didn't look at all how the
entity expected it was like a bar a
counter with rows of bottles behind it a
jukebox playing in the corner a man
stood behind the bar cleaning the
glasses the counterbalance the
administrator he said well there you are
certainly took your time can I pour you
a little something this only served to
increase the black Moon's confusion it
had form here dark smoke compressed into
a vaguely humanoid shape it could speak
it could think none of this may made any
sense the being that had just wiped out
all conscious life and seen the very
death of the universe was truly and
utterly confused the administrator just
seemed to be enjoying himself preparing
for a confrontation hundreds of billions
of years in the making the singular
conceptual bunker or perhaps the
singular containment bunker was a truly
ingenious creation a place of pure ideas
where everything inside was on the same
level here there were no Immortals no
Gods just ideas on the same Level
Playing Field and it was time for the
black Moon's idea to come to an end it
was a trap and the entire universe was
the bait without warning the
administrator pulled up a shotgun from
underneath the table and Unleashed both
barrels into the black Moon's chest the
creature took the head and fought back
dragging the administrator to the ground
beating him strangling him he could feel
the light fading under the monster
Monster's Relentless assault until he
managed to get his desperate hands on a
glass ashtray he beat the monster over
the head with it until it's gripped
loosened and he was able to slide out
there the killer of the universe was on
the ground before him he grabbed the
monster held it in place and beat it to
death he was Gravely injured by the
battle but the black moon was no more
here in the singular conceptual bunker
he had won the administrator no longer
the counterbalance in the absence of the
black moon hobbled over to the Jukebox
produced a single beautiful coin from
his pocket he pushed the coin into the
slot wheezed a pain breath and said the
thing is this place is only information
there's nothing else out there not even
matter the universe closed its doors a
long time ago this place can go from
information back to matter with just the
Press of a button
let's see what happens when we introduce
something to nothing for a second it
looks as though he might fall but he
doesn't instead he slams the button on
the jukebox and with a relieve laugh
says let there be light and there was
light the fabric of our world is
littered with strange doorways if you
know where to look for them tares
portals anomalies all leading to places
and planes Beyond human imagining and
understanding an scp-2317 otherwise
known as a door to another world
certainly fits that description
contained and kept at all times under
the watch of armed guards
scp-2317 appears to be a simple and
unsuspecting wooden door in its frame
it hardly looks like it requires such
extreme round-the-clock security or
needs a strange secretive ritual that
the foundation performs presumably to
keep the door closed
but of course sometimes the most
interesting thing about a closed doorway
isn't where it leads it's what it keeps
out
even by the foundation's already high
standards the requirements and
regulations for personnel who are
assigned to scp-2317 seem oddly specific
psychological testing is standard
practice to work for the foundation but
an additional hurdle that anyone has to
clear before even getting to Glimpse at
this unassuming wooden door is having a
score of at least 72 on the Milgram
obedience examination
it is also mandatory that Personnel
assigned to maintaining it are both
unmarried with no children or next of
kin as well as an unwavering
unquestioning loyalty to the foundation
pure devotion to its code and objectives
these may seem like strange requirements
after all
scp-2317 is just a door isn't it
perhaps there's a reason that the
foundation keeps so much of the
information about
scp-2317 buried deep under layers upon
layers of security with only the
overseer Council privy to the full
details of its strange nature
knowledge as they say is power but maybe
knowing too much about whatever is
behind that door can prove deadly
still if
scp-2317 is a door to another world an
alternate Dimension or parallel reality
it must be safe enough to visit after
all the foundation has been sending
Personnel in there on a regular basis
daily in fact
according to the o5 council this is done
as part of a procedure to maintain
active containment of something lurking
beyond that old wooden door frame
but what could possibly Warren such
constant maintenance and surveillance
in accordance with the foundation's
guidelines all staff are required to
rotate out of observing scp-2317 after
every two months and spend the following
third month in full psychological
counseling before they are permitted to
return to the containment unit housing
the door to another world
it was after one of these month-long
periods of evaluation that a foundation
guard was informed that his security
clearance has been raised to level three
and that he'd been selected for the duty
of carrying out 220 Calabasas he knew
the name instantly
this was the title given to the Daily
containment procedure that absolutely
had to be carried out
the guard didn't question these orders
after all he'd been selected precisely
because of his loyalty to the foundation
he did make one request to his
commanding officer however
he wanted to know what had happened to
the last guard that had performed the
procedure
didn't make it out of psychological
evaluation
the officer replied
not letting this affect his dedication
the guard was told to prepare for
procedure 220 Calabasas
along with a fellow member of foundation
security personnel
guard was instructed to gather
everything on a strange list
the first was a pre-selected member of
Class D personnel specifically a
convicted murderer class D refers to
disposable class Personnel a Expendable
individuals recruited by the foundation
for the sole purpose of testing scps
class D's were usually prison inmates
repurposed for SCP testing and the one
chosen for 220 Calabasas was no
exception serving multiple life
sentences for murders or at least that's
what the guard had been told
a foundation Personnel member instructed
him to refer to the class D's solely as
the assistant from that point on
next the guard collected a live chicken
an obsidian edged knife a silver
asparagulum and aspersorium to be filled
with 500 cc's of holy water that have
been blessed by a priest of the
abrahamic faith and finally a one
kiloton nuclear device which according
to instructions was only to be detonated
in the unlikely event of a catastrophic
containment failure in other words The
Last Resort
after following his instructions to the
letter and without question the guard
and his colleague were briefed the
foundation Personnel member informed
them that he'd be joining and leading
them in the procedure the staff member
also specified that henceforth he'd be
referred to as the celebrant until the
completion of 220 Calabasas the guard
was acutely aware of how specific these
instructions were but trusted in the
foundation knowing that if they wanted
this procedure performed a certain way
then it was in everyone's best interest
to carry out the orders to the letter
but what the celebrant then went on to
explain raised far more questions about
scp-2317s and the nature of procedure
220 Calabasas
the class D joining them wasn't actually
a Class D
the assistant as they were now referred
to was in reality another Foundation
staff member with a level 4 security
clearance specifically tailored to
scp-2317 every member of Staff entering
through
scp-2317 and taking an active role in 22
Calabasas needed to be informed that
this assistant was not to be harmed or
treated as a member of disposable class
fighting back the nagging question of
why the foundation would employ this
subterfuge the guard along with his
fellow security officer the celebrant
and assistant prepared for their
departure through the door to another
world at solar noon when the sun was
highest over scp-2317
solar noon chickens and holy water
this all seemed like an oddly occult
combination for the foundation
as they entered the old wooden door
Beyond lay a Barren salt plain
stretching out for kilometers in every
direction
this alternate Dimension according to
the briefing was designated
scp-2317 Prime the guard immediately
noticed a ring of Seven Pillars directly
ahead of the group as they entered
each of them bearing intricately
detailed Engravings unlike anything from
any era of ancient history
procedure 220 Calabasas was carried out
quickly but carefully the guard watching
as the celebrant and assistant were
careful not to miss a step
first the celebrant scattered holy water
into the center of the pillars with the
aspergulum and aspersorium
looking down at his feet and keeping a
steady Pace as he stepped
counterclockwise around them the guard
watched intently as the celebrant
completed his circuit around the pillars
and turned to the assistant
anointing his head with holy water
Seven Seals seven rings
seven Thrones for the Scarlet King he
said aloud
the assistant with the obsidian blade in
his hand took the chicken and dispatched
it in sacrifice
letting its blood mix with the holy
water
he then repeated the celebrant circuit
in the opposite direction before
stepping into the center of the stone
pillars
blood for the old gods water for the new
king the assistant recited pouring the
remaining mix of blood and holy water
over a patch of salt in the middle of
the Seven Pillars
even though he knew it wasn't his place
to question the foundation as the 220
Calabasas procedure took place the guard
couldn't help but wonder what all this
was for
it seems so ritualistic like something
deeply religious or even magical he
never bought into all that occult mumbo
jumbo even while working for the
foundation but he had learned not to
question anything even the strangest and
most inexplicable of science
little did he know that beneath his feet
was an ancient and unknowable horror a
beast Chained and lying in weight
contained in a chamber directly
underneath the pillars sat an impossibly
large creature humanoid and obese its
body covered entirely in Scales thicker
than armor plating
branch-like horns protruded from its
jawless head pointing up to chains that
hung from the Seven Pillars above
each one hooked into the entity's back
all but one of the chains was broken a
final withering shackle keeping the
Devourer of worlds in its underground
prison
ever since 1894 BCE when origin Mystics
imprisoned it the Devourer has been
waiting patiently for its inevitable
freedom it knows as well as the
foundation that nothing can be done to
prevent the final chain from one day
breaking
even procedure 220 Calabasas won't keep
the creature contained it's nothing more
than a smoke screen an act designed to
create an illusion of active containment
and maintain Foundation morale until a
permanent solution can be devised to
keep
scp-2317 imprisoned of course if the
guard had known this it would have also
explained the need for a one kiloton
nuclear device as part of this stage
ritual
procedure 220 Calabasas had all the
components to trick everyone below the
o5 council emulating religious and
occult rituals The increased level of
security surrounding the procedure and
its purpose
and telling staff that any failure to
correctly and completely perform the 220
Calabasas procedure will result in an XK
Class end of the world scenario
all these elements work together to
conceal the truth that one day the
Devourer will escape and lay waste to
our dimension
knowledge is power and maybe knowing too
much truly is deadly perhaps if the
guard had learned any of this he'd have
understood why his predecessor never
made it out of psychological evaluation
maybe if you had questioned the purpose
of procedure 220 Calabasas he'd have
learned the true nature of scp-2317
and what that doorway kept out
but he was loyal to the foundation
through and through
as the team finished performing 220
Calabasas and returned through the
wooden door the guard took one last
glance over his shoulder at the vast
salt plane
the entire Dimension was calm silent
but not peaceful it was patient The
Entity had waited centuries for its time
and now all it would take was the
breaking of the seventh and final chain
one day the door was closed behind the
guard as he the celebrant the assistant
and his fellow security officers stepped
back through
their work done and as far as they knew
preventing catastrophe for another day
only the foundation higher-ups the
overseer Council are aware of the true
danger posed by
scp-2317 and its sole inhabitant
current predictions are that at some
point within the next 30 Years the
Devourer of Worlds will be freed
any in all attempts to repair or
recreate the chains holding it in place
have so far failed
as such the o5 council has elected to
continue providing Foundation personnel
with the ignorant hope that procedure
220 Calabasas is an effective strategy
for containment as we've said
sometimes the most interesting thing
about a closed door isn't where it leads
it's what it keeps out
in the case of
scp-2317 the unassuming wooden door
holds at Bay an ancient creature of
Untold power
that will one day break free and wreak
havoc in our dimension
nothing the foundation does can prevent
it or keep it contained behind the door
to another world
and only the overseer Council knows that
any and all efforts to do so are futile
with all that in mind we can only hope
that the doorway of
scp-2317 stays closed at least for a
little while longer
it was July of 2004 and Bill Murray was
enjoying the peak of an extremely
successful career
not only had the iconic actors starred
in some of the most beloved comedies of
the 20th century including Ghostbusters
and Groundhog Day he'd voiced the main
character of the recently released
live-action Garfield movie it been a
financial success but it was a critical
flop not that this bothered Bill he was
happy with the performance and the paint
Shack
Woody wouldn't be quite as happy about
was the horrifying encounter he was
about to have with scp-3166
on July 8th bill was enjoying a cold
drink on the porch of his luxurious
Beverly Hills Home the sky was beginning
to darken as the sun set in the west it
was a blissful evening his wife Jennifer
was inside watching TV nothing seemed
particularly out of the ordinary until
he noticed a quick flash of orange in
the distance it was almost too fast to
register this large orange-shaped
darting past the corner of his eye for a
second he entertained the thought that
it might have been an escaped Tiger but
it was gone too fast to really tell Bill
finished his drink and headed inside he
had enough for one night the next
morning he got up to read the paper and
found the Garfield movie getting
slaughtered by the critics one review
stated no one can accuse Garfield the
movie of infidelity to its source it
Faithfully conveys the banality of Jim
Davis's cartoon another called it a film
without energy and without spirit
put the paper down and ate his breakfast
a few blows to the ego were worth it for
the paydays that came with big budget
family films just then his wife came to
him with a strange question were you
walking around downstairs in the middle
of the night no he hadn't he'd been
sleeping like a baby why did she ask
well Jennifer said I heard some rustling
downstairs last night
sounded like something big
he hadn't heard anything though and told
her it was probably just Her Imagination
he put it out of his mind and continued
about his day he decided he would keep
his eyes peeled for that orange blur
again though Bill didn't see anything
peculiar the rest of the morning and
went to a local cafe for lunch he
ordered a coffee and a cream cheese
bagel then made a quick trip to the
bathroom while his food was prepared
when Bill returned to his table though
there was something strange
instead of a bagel there was a large
heaping of lasagna on the table what was
going on this Cafe didn't even serve
lasagna Bill knew something was terribly
wrong things only got stranger when bill
came home to find a small tuft of orange
Furs snagged on the frame of his front
door and it wasn't synthetic for her
like you'd see on plush toys or stuffed
animals no this was real animal fur
maybe someone was just goofing off or
trying to play some weird prank on him
but it didn't feel like it
deep down Bill Murray knew that he was
in grave danger whoever or whatever was
behind this
it wanted to hurt him that night his
worst fears were realized Bill's wife
had left town for the week and he was
headed to the kitchen in the middle of
the night for a glass of water when he
saw something a huge figure moving up
against the glass door leading to his
backyard the thing was huge nearly seven
feet tall with a bloated fur-covered
misshapen body that was pressed up
against the door its fur was bright
garish orange a cartoon Orange
strangest of all though was the sound it
was making
it sounded like it was purring Bill
backed away from the door and then ran
back to his room to hide the whole night
he sat cowering as he heard scratching
against the walls like something was
trying to get in he was terrified and
too scared to do anything even move
finally as morning broke the noises
seemed to stop Bill had to do something
he couldn't let this nightmare go on
another night what if things got worse
what if that thing managed to get inside
he called the local police and when they
arrived he explained the incredibly
strange situation as best he could he
told them he was being stalked by some
kind of huge cat or at least someone
dressed like a huge cat also there was
lasagna involved the officers
interviewing him could barely contain
their laughter as he told them his story
a giant orange cat perhaps one of them
theorized he angered some kind of
obsessive Garfield fan through his
involvement in the live-action movie
after all the original comic had been
running for years and had been extremely
popular who knows what kind of nut jobs
were obsessed with seeing only a
faithful adaptation of the source
material as the officers departed bill
was confident that they weren't taking
him seriously he couldn't rely on any of
them for protection thankfully from a
multi-decade movie career he had plenty
of disposable income and decided to hire
a private security team to protect him
while he looked into this mystery he had
two trained bodyguards positioned around
his home at all times for the next month
they were armed and given the cryptic
orders to fire on anything orange
meanwhile Bill began to Fall Down A
Garfield Rabbit Hole he felt strangely
compelled to research all the Garfield
media he could find as though the answer
to his terrifying situation was somehow
hidden between the lines Bill explored
the entire backlog of thousands of comic
strips he read the books and interviews
with Jim Davis he watched the cartoons
and straight to DVD animated movies
ironically for a guy who'd recently
portrayed the lasagna loving orange cat
Bill had never felt quite so immersed in
the character before
he found the strange Pathos in the
routine of Garfield and his friends one
particular comic really piqued his
interest though originally published in
October of 1989 the comic began with
Garfield being woken up by a strange
Chell an almost Eerie sensation the
character observed aloud that he didn't
feel like he was in his own home he
explored his little home further trying
to find his owner John or his housemate
and sometimes Nemesis Odie but found
nothing has Garfield remarked on feeling
alone a purple speechbox delivered the
Sinister message
you have no idea how alone you are
Garfield
he then finds that his home looks like
it's been abandoned for years
the for sale sign outside is practically
ancient
Garfield slowly comes to a horrifying
revelation
everyone really is gone and his
adventures and friends now exist only in
his imagination he's trapped in a prison
of his own creation trying to Stave off
his endless loneliness in denial about
the reality of his situation the comic
ended with a quote directly from Jim
Davis himself saying an imagination is a
powerful tool a Content memories of the
past shade perceptions of the present or
paint a future so vivid that it can
entice or terrify
all depending upon how we conduct
ourselves today as he read those words
Bill Murray felt a chilled on his spine
why had he wanted to get involved in the
Garfield movie in the first place what
had he gotten himself into before he
could slip any deeper into his own mind
Bill heard a faint choked screen
downstairs
felt his breath catch in his throat he
was terrified but needed to see what was
happening
be carefully and quietly began to creep
down the stairs at the bottom he poked
his head around a corner and that's when
he saw a member of his security detail
lying dead on the floor his face was
Blue from asphyxiation his mouth was
stuffed with lasagna
it looked like he had been force-fed to
death
Bill wanted to scream but he couldn't or
maybe knew he shouldn't just then he
heard a soft meaty thumping noise coming
from the nearby living room he didn't
know why but he felt compelled to
approach as if by forces Beyond his
control he made his way to the living
room and when he'd got there he saw
where the noise was coming from Bill's
jaw dropped in pure horror there was the
other member of his security detail
lying limp and lifeless under a giant
orange figure who was a grotesquely huge
creature wearing what looked to be a
kind of crude Garfield outfit made of
sewn together cat palettes it stank of
pasta and rotten meat in its giant Paw
It held the golden trophy which it was
using to pound the security guard's head
into mush while making quiet cat-like
purring noises the creature suddenly
stopped and looked up locking eyes with
Bill the fear of death came over him he
froze as the giant freakish Garfield
stepped over Donny's corpse and began to
come towards him bill turned and ran but
Garfield was gaining on him before he
could make it to the front door the
creature knocked him over he was laid
out on the ground looking up at it as it
reached into its own body cavity and
began to pull out handfuls of lasagna he
was about to shove a wad of the horrible
decaying pasta into Bill's mouth when
suddenly a ding Was Heard and the
creature stopped
looked up as if sniffing the air and
then suddenly turned and lumbered
towards the kitchen
Bill watched as the Garfield monster
entered the kitchen where somehow there
was a steaming hot fresh lasagna sitting
in the open oven the creature had sensed
the presence of external lasagna and
felt the compulsion to integrate it into
its body grabbing fistfuls and shoving
it into itself
just then a group of highly trained SCP
Foundation Personnel burst into the room
and subdued the creature
I'd been in Ambush the foundation had
been tipped off to the presence of the
creature by monitoring the local police
department dispatches and the report of
a seven foot tall comic book cat
terrorizing a Hollywood actor was
definitely worth looking into the
monster that had almost taken Bill
Murray's life was
scp-3166 a deadly pathophysical being
that tends to manifest around people
somehow involved in the Garfield
intellectual property it appears
whenever the public perception of
Garfield falls out of favor and because
Bill had starred in the critically pan
Garfield movie he was currently at the
very top of
scp-3166's Hit List
thankfully he managed to survive his
terrifying ordeal and was administered
amnestics by Foundation Personnel so
that he could return to his normal life
this frightening and mysterious creature
has been around since 1989 appearing
after the publication of The Haunting
Garfield comic that Bill had read that
very night
it appeared in the office of United
media who were the Publishers of the
Garfield comic strip at the time and
began wrecking Havoc since then the
creature's manifestation has been a
constant threat whenever Garfield loses
its popularity or audience as a result
the foundation has spent years as the
funding source behind all Garfield media
and even planting hypnotic memetics into
the comic strips to ensure that there is
always a loyal fan base
the fur is indeed real organic cat fur
albeit an unnaturally orange color and
instead of organs the creature is filled
with lasagna worst of all though is that
testing has revealed that the meat in
the lasagna is genetically identical to
the Flesh of Garfield's Creator Jim
Davis how did this thing come into
existence perhaps it was Jim's sheer
force of imagination that dragged it
into being as he himself said an
imagination is a powerful tool all in
all it's lucky that Bill Murray was able
to survive his encounter and return to
his normal life well as normal as life
can be for Bill Murray and if you see
Bill Murray don't bother asking him
about scp-3166
the amnestics were quite effective and
just as he's fond of saying himself
no one will ever believe you if there's
anything that recent years have sadly
taught us it's that diseases are an
Insidious and formidable enemy that can
take you by surprise whether it's
bacterial a virus a fungal infection or
even an unfortunate genetic mutation
like cancer Alzheimer's or multiple
sclerosis sometimes dealing with a
dangerous pathogen could leave you
praying for a run-in with scp-682 after
all at least getting devoured by a giant
evil reptile is a quick death but take a
page out of the SCP foundation's book
Sometimes the best response to an
imminent threat is containment and
research one of the first rules of
combat is to know your enemy it may seem
like a tall order to have to write the
book on dangerous diseases but
thankfully that book has already been
written it's
scp-1025 the Encyclopedia of common
diseases this handy reader-friendly
volume will tell you everything you need
to know about all the common maladies
you may find yourself facing and a whole
lot more from the sniffles to lung
cancer from a cold sore to necrotizing
fasciitis you may be thinking why would
I need some dusty old book to tell me
about diseases I can always just go to
WebMD but you don't want that you know
what the internet is like they'll just
tell you you're sick and you don't want
them putting silly ideas in your head
like that how about you open up to a
random page and we'll take a look there
see the common cold classic let's see
the description the common cold is a
virus that affects the upper respiratory
tract its duration is typically a
maximum of two weeks and its primary
symptoms include headaches muscle aches
a cough a runny nose raise temperature
pressure in the ears or face and loss of
taste or smell see simple
straightforward and objective exactly
what you need
did you just cough that's strange and
come to think of it your nose is looking
a little red do you need a tissue or
perhaps a throat lozenge your voice
seems a little hoarse perhaps you ought
to take a break and lay down you really
don't look so good seems like the common
cold to us thankfully you shouldn't have
to worry about it for more than two
weeks oh and that reminds me there is a
certain anomalous effect to the
Encyclopedia of common diseases whenever
you read about a pathogen in the
encyclopedia of common diseases you
catch it manifesting even its most
severe symptoms in an extremely brief
period of time of course this isn't that
much of a problem if you just read the
article about having a sore throat or a
stomach bug but what if you read the
page for Ebola suddenly you're half dead
and bleeding from the eyes or the
Bubonic plague or a disease that
Humanity has never even faced before and
what if worst of all the people who
catch the diseases from this book can
continue to be contagious to others it
could be the basis for a world
destroying biological weapon and at the
very least a bona fide cutter class
anomaly when the SCP Foundation got
their hands on this little hardcover
anomalous nightmare the researchers
handling this thing realized it needed
to be kept under lock and key a new
provisional site was created just to
contain and research it without the risk
of its anomalous effects starting an
Unstoppable Global pandemic the base was
an isolated underground bunker
containing an even more high security
containment unit to store the book
itself a vault surrounded by at least 10
armed guards at any given time rotated
twice weekly and checked for any
infectious agents there was even a
powerful thermite bomb stored beneath
the Vault set to go off and annihilate
the entire chamber if the plausible risk
of a Containment Breach was detected it
may seem insane to put in this many
security fill safes for a simple
anomalous book but the SCP Foundation
has dealt with dangerous books before
take scp-140 also known as an incomplete
Chronicle this dangerous historical
volume Chronicles the living history of
the devites an extinct culture of
sadistic Sorcerers closely tied to the
Mythos of the Scarlet King whenever ink
or blood is brought into the presence of
this book it absorbs the material
expanding the devite history and
bringing their terrifying rule ever
closer to the modern day or take
scp-3512 the more you know a pickup
artist's Bible a deadly instruction
manual made by a mind controlling group
of interests known as the fifthists this
book gave its Sinister practitioners the
tools to control the minds of their
potential romantic Partners often
leading to their deaths while it may not
be quite as apocalyptic as scp-1025 or
scp-140 the fact that there are so many
in circulation still makes it a
dangerous threat point is a book can be
a dangerous thing especially if it's
pages have the potential to unlock
deadly diseases like
scp-1025 as you can expect with an
infectious ketterclass anomaly of this
magnitude procedures around this one
were rigorous the site staff was a
skeleton crew observing strict
quarantine procedures to prevent any
potential infection from leaking out
into the wider World Research into the
history of the book was inconclusive
despite a bevia foundation resources
being poured into finding any worthwhile
leads on the author or publisher of the
book nothing it was an absolute mystery
who or what had put this XK Class end of
the world scenario waiting to happen
here on Earth but now it was the job of
these Intrepid researchers to discover
the full extent of its potential dangers
27 d-class subjects were allocated to
the base for testing by the time the
process was over none of these unlucky
prisoners would remain alive the test
started much like this video the
researchers forced a d-class to read the
section on the a common cold within two
hours the subject began coughing upon
being asked they also reported feeling
physically anchy though they attributed
the egg to sleeping on an uncomfortable
d-class Cod every night the researchers
were concerned already the incubation
period for the common cold meaning the
period a person is infected before
showing active symptoms can be as long
as three days two hours is unprecedented
next a d-class was told to read the
section on Chickenpox a common childhood
malady that can be considerably more
dangerous in adulthood within an hour of
being exposed the d-class repeatedly
scratched no less than five points on
her body repeatedly while she claimed
that this was because of the Itchy
d-class jumpsuits it was too eerily
close to a symptom of chickenpox to be
ignored the medical history of this
d-class also showed that she'd suffered
chickenpox in childhood suggesting that
scp-1025 infections have the power to
override previous immunities next things
got a little more serious they tested
the section on lung cancer on a d-class
with no family history of lung
conditions not long after the
researchers noted that the d-class
coughed an unusual number of times not
only that they picked up irregularities
in the d-class's breathing that appeared
to be characteristic of lung cancer
while the d-class did not report any
feelings of chest pain or discomfort the
researchers had him terminated and
dissected no tumors were found a
researcher noted that they didn't wait
long enough for proper tumor
manifestation they knew they heard that
d-class coughing the researchers were so
concerned by the results of the previous
tests they repeated it exactly with
another d-class who they then observed
over a period of seven days to track
tumor manifestation researchers made a
note of an unusual amount of coughing
and wheezing from the subject over this
period of time the d-class was then
terminated and dissected but surprise
surprise no tumors researchers began to
consider the frightening possibility
that signs of
scp-1025-induced illnesses disappear
after the victims die meaning that a
pandemic started by scp-1025 would be
impossible to properly track and respond
to things were only getting scarier and
scarier for the scp-1025 researchers
sequestered away in that isolated
Foundation bunker researchers continued
to delve further into the lung cancer
Rabbit Hole this time however they
didn't wait for the subject to die
before looking at their insides they
instead performed a vivisection on the
subject only to find that despite the
victims still being alive and displaying
some of the key symptoms of lung cancer
there were no tumors what could this
mean these diseases weren't behaving
like any of their non-anomalous
counterparts what other differences
could we be dealing with here infectious
lung cancer and what if there are more
books out there like time bombs just
waiting to go off the tests continued
get getting more isolated and more
intense in the end the scp-1025 site was
staffed by only three researchers and
two agents acting as guards d-classes
were sent in one by one to minimize
ration requirements it seemed that they
could have been dealing with one of the
most dangerous anomalies of all time
even working with it could be a trigger
for the apocalypse if the proper
containment and quarantine procedures
weren't observed things got so out of
hand that a d-class without an appendix
was told to read the section on
appendicitis and researchers still
observed him exhibiting symptoms of the
condition he was vivisected and while
the appendix was still not present the
organs in the area where the appendix
would have been seemed redder than usual
when would this nightmare end well it
would actually end much sooner than
anyone involved would anticipate despite
never even reading scp-1025 himself a
researcher developed a strange
persistent cough and was quarantined in
a containment chamber by his concerned
colleagues on the seventh day of his
containment he seemed to be slightly
taller than before a symptom of
scp-016 a deadly anomalous bloodborne
pathogen that multiplies wildly and
rewrites the genetic structure of its
hosts if placed into a high stress
situation this led to a number of
terrifying Revelations not only did the
book have the potential to inflict a
number of anomalous diseases but it
could also potentially do so by pure
proximity even if you don't actually
read it what other anomalous diseases
could be on the table now what about
scp-008 a terrifying prion with both 100
virality and 100 lethality or scp-742 a
retrovirus that slowly but surely
transforms its victims into
cannibalistic monsters or even the
horrifying
scp-217 the disease that slowly converts
your entire body into a mechanical
nightmare there would be no limit to the
horrors scp-1025 could unleash on the
world if it ever got out they needed to
keep this thing locked up at any cost
that's when the infected researcher
escaped and all hell broke loose the
isolated facility went dark for 72 hours
after not being able to get into contact
with any other Foundation bases during
that time a recovery team was sent to
investigate the Mystery One agent and
one researcher were found in the
observation Booth wearing biological
containment suits another agent was
found crawling through the air ducts
with this handgun drawn a crazed look in
his eye an additional researcher had
locked himself in the barracks with a
homemade flamethrower paranoid about
infection and the final agent was found
dead in a storage locker with some empty
bottles and ration packages after having
given the door an airtight seal to
prevent infection then dying of
Suffocation inside the o5 council
shuttered the entire investigation a
scp-1025 was downgraded from ketter to
Safe class then placed in a storage
locker the whole thing was considered a
wash we know what you're probably
wondering why if this anomaly was so
incredibly dangerous why on Earth would
the o5 council and the rest of the
foundation be dealing with it so
casually well that's simple the initial
batch of researchers had grievously
misjudged the actual anomalous effect of
scp-1025 it doesn't give diseases to
those who read its text instead it
induces a form of hypochondria by proxy
to those around the reader in other
words while scp-1025 has no effect on
the reader it makes everyone around them
merely believe that they've come down
with a terrible illness the few members
of Staff in that isolated site had been
killing and dissecting d-classes for no
reason in effect it all effectively gone
mad due to the anomalous effects of
scp-1025 and the paranoia in used by
pressure and isolation much like your
average hypochondriac they warped the
data to fit the worst possible outcome
rather than the most mundane and likely
as an old medical expression goes when
you see hoof prints think horses not
zebras the entire thing had been a
terrifying waste of time money and human
life so perhaps in the end the
Encyclopedia of common diseases is a lot
more like WebMD than we thought it's not
nearly as useful as getting a
consultation with an actual doctor and
of course it's liable to put some very
strange ideas in your head there is
something so captivating about ice it
can be beautiful a shimmering cast of
frost over a meadow or twinkling icicles
on a cottage roof it can also be deadly
a slick of slippery glass on a dark Road
or that same icicle from before knocking
loose and careening towards your head
like a falling down tiger it can be a
sleet storm or a mighty Glacier with
Secrets buried beneath its core in a
remote part of Alaska the SCP Foundation
discovered a particularly unusual kind
of ice with a vivid red Hue and some
incredibly deadly potential the
foundation investigated the reports in a
remote area on the Alaskan Coastline
after a tribe of Local Natives came
across the mangled bodies of Shipwrecked
hunters in the area encased in a block
of strange Red Ice mobile task force
beta 7 also known as the hazmatters were
sent into the site to determine what
exactly had occurred and take samples of
any anomalous materials to be brought
back to the nearest Foundation research
site agent Bryce made the initial visual
inspection of the site and spotted three
middle-aged male bodies further
examination determined that one of the
bodies referred to as subject zero was
the original point of contamination for
whatever comprised the Red Ice and cause
was the men's deaths it has been posited
by the investigation team that the other
men were infected when they attempted to
help subject zero reach their boat sadly
kindness can sometimes be a killer like
that while sweeping the perimeter agent
Hughes spotted human Footprints leading
to the Northeast the three men team
consisting of agent Hughes Whitmore and
Cassidy was permitted to follow those
tracks and determine if any survivors or
something worse had escaped the site
exploration log a009 allows us to
determine what happened next and what
the three agents found Hughes and his
team followed the footprints to the
entrance of a cave with the tracks
appearing to lead inside the entrance of
the cave was covered with an almost
solid sheet of ice save for a crack in
the ice about one meter tall Beyond this
wall agent Whitmore spotted the body of
a young man frozen solid in the midst of
crawling away from something covered in
crystals of Red Ice with him was a
frozen spear gun that appeared to have
been fired just before the young man's
death they could not touch the body to
perform a full investigation but the way
in which he was gripping his chest
indicated that he might have been
fatally stabbed there as the agents
moved further into the cave they
discovered a chamber about five or six
meters in diameter filled with red ice
with a pool in the middle the pool was
three meters wide and of an unknown
depth as they pushed further the agents
came across a polar bear startled they
fired once at it before realizing it was
already dead its fur was dotted with
crystals of Red Ice creeping its way
across the Bear's body beyond the polar
bear the agent spotted dozens of bodies
all dead animals there were seals a snow
fox and finally a giant spider with a
leg span of over a meter at first the
spider appeared to be Frozen like the
other creatures but upon further
investigation it appeared to be made of
red red eyes agent Cassidy recognized
the spider as scp-3023 but was told it
was impossible when she pressed for
further answers she was told to ignore
it and continue the sweep agent Whitmore
checked the collection of bodies in the
chamber looking for any humans among
them meanwhile Hughes spotted a spear
sticking out of the enormous spider
indicating a struggle that took place
before it and the young man at the
Cave's entrance froze Hughes was
interrupted in his task as agent Cassidy
called out from deeper in the cave
saying I think I know where the spider
came from when Hughes followed the sound
of her voice he found something
troubling an aperture about a meter in
diameter absolutely covered in Red Ice
it looked like a tunnel with no ice at
all past its entrance with a dim light
coming from somewhere deep inside he
lost sight of agent Cassidy and realized
she must have gone inside of it upon
further observation Hughes determined
that the walls and the floor of the
tunnel were
with a red puddle about a meter in
Hughes and Whitmore called to Cassidy
attempting to lead her back out of the
tunnel but received no response he was
attempted to go in and retrieve her but
control forbade him from going any
further after a conversation with
control that had been stricken from the
official file Hughes had relented and
agreed to withdraw his remaining team
and exit the site using Whitmore left
the cave without further incident and
returned to Foundation headquarters in
spite of a d-class recovery team being
sent into the cave to search for her
agent Cassidy's body was never found the
cave was blocked off from the public in
order to avoid further civilian contact
with the red ice and the red water
inside though the origin of the Red Ice
in Alaska is not known for sure this
cave and the pool deep within it are
thought to be the source of this
particular infestation the official
cause of death listed on record for the
bodies found in Alaska was internal
bleeding but what really happened to
them was something much much worse these
men had transformed and Frozen from the
inside out their blood turning to ice
and their cells going solid one at a
time the low ambient temperature in the
area are thought to have slowed the
freezing process down you heard that
right the cold kept them from freezing
faster as counter-intuitive as it sounds
this prolonged their deaths and kept
them conscious up until the very end
even as their bodies were freezing solid
their very cells turning against them
they were awake and aware of it all
these unfortunate men came into contact
with and lost their lives to a substance
known as
scp-009
scp-009 in its liquid form maintained at
temperatures between negative 100 and 0
degrees Celsius resembles ordinary
distilled water aside from its bright
red color it behaves opposite of water
reaching a frozen solid state at higher
temperatures and vaporizing into a
steam-like gas at temperatures below
negative 100 degrees
an attempt to examine
scp-009's atomic structure was unable to
achieve conclusive results the substance
looks as if it was made up of normal
water molecules though obviously it is
much more than simple water
scp-009 appears relatively harmless at
first glance but its real dangerous
potential lies in its ability to
contaminate water-based Solutions
transferring its properties to them a
contaminated liquid begins to exhibit
the same unusual behavior as scp-009
freezing at temperatures above zero
degrees and vaporizing at temperatures
below negative 100 it has been shown to
effectively contaminate ice steam tea
fruit juice seawater and blood and a
process taking between three minutes and
several hours these concerning
properties raise questions about what
scp-009 and liquids contaminated by it
might do if they made contact with a
human body several d-class Personnel
were used as test subject checks exposed
to scp-009 in a controlled environment
and observed from a safe distance when
first exposed to scp-009 the test
subjects reported nothing unusual they
accept a slight sensation of warming on
the surface of their skin then Frost
began to form across the surface of the
exposed area as the subject's body heat
raised the substance's temperature this
process took between a minute and a few
hours during which ice crystals began to
form along the top layer of the skin
this stage is known as surface
conversion in the next stage deep tissue
conversion the continued increase in
scp-009's temperature causes a ripple
effect of reactions through the
subject's body ice crystals forming in
the cells and throughout the blood the
subject remained alive and conscious
during the stage details about the
fourth stage of the process had been
expunged from the official record but it
is safe to say that something horrible
happened after several of these
experiments were conducted testing on
live d-class subjects was officially
discontinued there was a possibility of
experimentation on scp-009 regarding its
potential application to Cold Fusion but
this was also eventually discontinued
following a disastrous accident at an
unnamed Foundation test site the site
was completely destroyed and pieces of
the lead agent conducting the cold
fusion research have still not been
recovered for now scp-009 is kept under
strict containment and only tested under
particular highly regulated
circumstances
scp-009 is kept in a sealed storage tank
of heat resistant alloy it is not to be
exposed to any temperatures higher than
zero degrees Celsius unless there is
official Foundation sanction testing
being done no water-based liquids are
allowed within 30 meters of the
containment area the storage tank is
outfitted with temperature sensors that
are to be monitored at all times in
order to prevent the temperature within
from rising and is kept cold by three
different cool
if the sensors or cooling units
malfunction for any reason they must be
fixed immediately to prevent disaster
when testing is done on scp-009 the
containment area is kept in a vacuum and
the Personnel working with it must wear
protective gear after testing all
involved personnel must quarantine for
at least 12 hours any living organisms
contaminated by scp-009 must be
terminated promptly while the exact
origins of scp-009 are unclear it
clearly does not follow the laws of
nature as we understand them a
foundation expert in xenospatial physics
suggested that scp-009 may have come
from a universe with alternate laws of
physics explaining its reversal of the
ordinary conditions for states of matter
during an instance of scp-507 The
Reluctant Dimension Hopper shifting into
an alternate universe an instance of
scp-009 was unexpectedly observed and
may help confirm this theory in the test
air area where scp-507 appeared red snow
fell for about 27 minutes grass touched
by this red snow began to react and
freeze over within a few minutes the
other plant life touched by the snow
turned bright red and expanded to a
larger size it also began to sprout
bright blue tentacles covered with red
mucilage upon closer examination the
mucilage turned out to be comprised of
small amounts of
scp-009 this raised additional questions
for instance how are these plants able
to survive constant exposure to
scp-009 this matter is currently under
investigation but the prevailing theory
is that this plant is an example of
plant life from
scp-009's native Universe whatever it is
and wherever it comes from it should not
be allowed to come into contact with
earth-based Organic life forms well not
unless being horrifically frozen to
death by your own body feels like an
appealing experience to you the
coastline where SCP
009 was initially discovered and its
first victims on record were found was
located very close to the ocean
thankfully the exact area of
contamination was dry and cold enough to
keep the Red Ice from spreading but if
it had been even a few meters closer to
the water it could have spread into the
North Pacific Ocean with contamination
of that scale it could have very easily
infected thousands of people perhaps
spreading into other bodies of water and
triggering a global Extinction event
because of this threat several members
of the SCP Foundation proposed that
scp-009 be upgraded to ketter class in
order to reflect its danger to humanity
however this request was denied due to
the currently effective containment
measures in place the Red Ice is unable
to spread to new hosts infecting the
water supply and turning all living
things into frozen husks for now let's
just hope we don't see any red
snowstorms anytime soon there is
something maddening about a repetitive
of consistent sound don't you agree the
narrator of Edgar Allan Poe's The
Telltale Heart is driven mad by the
non-stop beating of a heart coming from
beneath his floorboards but even
something less horrible than a
disembodied heartbeat can Fray a
person's nerves superficially less
horrible anyway something as simple as
say the Relentless ticking of a clock
after all what could be more frightening
than a reminder of the sands of time
passing through our fingers of the
finite steps on life's long and winding
road we have the answer to that question
the scariest thing of all is the monster
waiting on the other side of the road
twisted and hungry the thing that
strikes when the ticking eventually
stops when time is up tick tock tick
tock
many years ago a clockmaker in the
German Town of Freiburg was renowned for
his ability to produce Exquisite
personalized clocks for his clientele
all across town the country and even
Beyond his unparalleled constructions
made him the only man to reach out to
when it came to getting your hands on a
beautiful ornate timepiece that would
ease the anxieties of the passing hours
he ate slept and breathed clocks it was
his life his calling as such the
clockmaker had grown accustomed to the
sound of ticking he heard it in the
morning when he awoke to The Cry of his
cuckoo clock he listened to it all day
in his Workshop as he repaired and
constructed clocks of all shapes and
sizes and it was the sound that lulled
him to sleep at night after each long
hard day it gave life a pleasant Rhythm
one day however he noticed a
particularly loud repetitive sound had
permeated his home it was rhythmic like
the ticking of his clocks but harsher
somehow it did not gently tick but
rather cracked like the way his knees
popped when a harsh winter was coming
something in it made his stomach ache
with Dread he began taking apart every
clock in his Workshop looking for the
source of the sound but still it
persisted he sat there at his desk
surrounded by gears and pieces of wood
Glass and Metal and still the sound
pounded against his eardrums tick tock
tick tock the clockmaker was stumped by
The Mysterious Ticking Noise it felt too
real too Vivid to be some kind of
hallucination he would have bet every
clock he ever made that the noise was
coming from outside of his head it was a
man so astute in his clockmaking
abilities that he could tell his own
Creations apart in the dark from the
mere Timber of their ticking but here he
was in the presence of an alien force
this frightening almost predatory sound
that lingered in his periphery always
somewhere but not confined to any fixed
point he was reminded vaguely of Peter
Pan of the crocodile that eaten Captain
Hook's hand and alarm clock which
survived and continued ticking in the
literal Belly of the Beast hook a
vicious pirate Captain would become a
gibbering wreck when the ticking sound
got closer did he fear the Predator whom
the ticking foretold or the passage of
time that pushed him further into the
Reaper's fold in the otherwise Immortal
plane of Neverland tick tock tick tock
the clockmaker's search continued he
turned his workplace upside down and
inside out in pursuit of this seemingly
sourceless ticking he checked every
hiding place every closet covered
cubbyhole and cabinet nothing he moved
the furniture tied up the curtains
rolled up all the carpets nothing in his
desperation he took a claw hammer from
his toolbox and began prying the rusty
nails from the ground before peeling up
the floorboards and checking the dusty
spider infested spaces underneath
perhaps some mechanism had fallen down
there or had always been there just
ticking away there had to be something
down there but no only dirt insects and
shadows maybe he was going mad maybe it
was tinnitus or the indelible impression
that hearing years upon years of ticking
had left in his mind the way an image is
burned into a plasma screen if it's left
there for too long maybe it was some
shadowy government agency trying to
drive him mad with the use of some new
sound based torture device oral
terrorism selective auditory subliminal
mind control Havana syndrome the
fizzling edges of Sanity egged On by The
Invisible long-range CIA telesound beams
their had to be some kind of explanation
but whatever the case the sound
persisted tick tock tick tock he
couldn't stay there and the dismembered
ruins of his prestigious clock making
shop any longer he was clearly under a
lot of stress here not healthy not good
for the mind he decided to close the
shop for a few days and go visit his
daughter and her family some time with
his beloved relatives would soothe his
frayed nerves so he packed his bag and
made the trip hoping that leaving work
behind for a few days would also loosen
up his mind but the entire drive to his
daughter's house he could have sworn he
still heard the sound keeping perfect
time as it cracked again and again he
shook his head scolding himself for
imagining things there was nothing in
the car that could be making that noise
he'd focused on it too much surely
that's why he was obsessing over it now
all this had a rational explanation he
simply thought himself he'd simply
thought himself into corner on this one
wouldn't that explain all of this all
just a trick in the mind of an
overworked clockmaker sorely in need of
a good sabbatical in the country this
wouldn't be forever tick tock tick tock
the clockmaker's daughter greeted him at
the door with a warm embrace and a
hearty meal and for a little while he
relaxed the sound of good company and
laughter drowned out the infernal
ticking he began to entertain the notion
that perhaps the ticking had been a good
thing it had been a long time since he'd
seen his daughter and that ticking as
frightening as it had been was also the
only thing that pushed him away from the
workshop for a while he was somewhat
grateful for a good excuse to take time
off perhaps that was what it was all
about a reminder to take it easy after a
weekend off he'd be right as rain surely
but that night as he tried to fall
asleep the sound was there again
taunting him keeping his eyes open wide
and his heart rate climbing was it the
Dark of the room magnifying his hearing
intensifying that awful ticking or was
it louder and closer than ever before it
felt as though an invisible clock like
so many he'd made before was hanging
over him but what was holding it that
awful awful sound like the bubbles
popping in the synovial fluids of a
person's aged and crumbling joints too
organic too fleshy and it just kept
getting louder and closer louder and
closer louder and closer tick tock tick
tock tick tock tick tock tick tock tick
tock
until suddenly it went silent he
breathed a sigh of relief and closed his
eyes the clockmaker's daughter woke to
the sound of her father's piercing
guttural screams she ran to his room to
find the bed sheets soaked with blood
the bedroom window shattered and her
father Gone without a trace she went to
the police the next day but they could
do nothing for her her father had not
been the victim of an ordinary murderer
or Thief but something outside the realm
of understanding it was something
ancient something mysterious something
monstrous something anomalous though the
police could do nothing another
organization was secretly on the case
the SCP Foundation after The
clockmaker's Disappearance operatives
searched the area and discovered the
culprit which they captured and
designated
scp-4975
scp-4975 is a humanoid entity with
bird-like features the most notable of
which which is a sharp pointed beak its
body is long and thin with bony limbs
with tapered points with no discernible
digits of any kind its body including
its beak is covered with a thick hard
layer of skin the entity's most notable
feature is not its appearance however
but in its skeleton particularly its
spine the cervical vertebrae of the
creature are not interconnected and are
capable of independent movement they
rotate one vertebra at a time from Back
to Front in order all the way up to the
entity's head in a particular Rhythm
this produces the clicking or cracking
sound that is so terribly familiar to
its intended victims it repeats the
motion constantly over and over again
only stopping when it's preparing to
attack its chosen prey
scp-4975 does not kill impulsively
simply selecting a convenient victim
instead it stalks its prey for months at
a time sometimes even a year following
them in darkness hiding just out of
sight the only sign of its presence is
that sound the clicking cracking tick
tock tick tock of its bones as it bides
its time knowing that it can wait as
long as it needs or wants to before it
strikes when it's ready to Feast it will
beat and tear at the victim's body with
the tapered points of its limbs
shredding the Flesh and pecking at it
much like a vulture rips at a fresh
carcass then it can Savor its meal using
the body as food for about three months
before it needs to hunt again though its
exact age is unknown it is theorized
that the creature is hundreds if not
thousands of years old written evidence
of its existence has been traced back as
far as the 1500s there are mentions of a
creature resembling
scp-4975 throughout German folklore
appearing in carvings paintings folk
tales and nursery rhymes one such
nursery rhyme was discovered and
translated by the foundation during the
research process though its rhyme scheme
was lost when it was translated to
English the Eerie feeling it evokes was
not the rhyme goes Tick Tock the cuckoo
clock ticks cuckoo the bird inside sings
tick tock tick tock tick tock tick tock
as it ticks the time so ticks your heart
may you live long as you hear its song
tick tock tick tock tick tock tick tock
listen close for when it stops the
hatchling comes out of its home tick
tock tick tock tick tock tick did you
hear it did it stop my child it meant
your time was up the research team
theorized that this nursery rhyme and
others like it was you used to warn
children about potential indicators of
danger from
scp-4975 and teach them to be wary of
its hunting patterns knowledge after all
is one of the best weapons in anyone's
arsenal when it comes to the anomalous
without much more knowledge than this
little poem provides and what they had
observed prior to
scp-4975's capture the SCP Foundation
did its best to create adequate
containment measures for the creature
currently
scp-4975 is kept in a standard steel
containment cell and is prohibited from
any direct human contact it can be
observed via security footage but no
human beings are permitted to go inside
lest they serve as the creature's next
meal if a Containment Breach occurs any
Personnel that report hearing a
repetitive cracking or ticking sound are
to be isolated until the entity has been
captured and placed back in its cell or
until the sound stops though scp-4975 is
currently contained there is a chance
that its captive state does not actually
make it any less lethal after a
harrowing incident that sent many
attending researchers to the on-site
psychologist's office the foundation was
given reason to believe that containing
it does not actually stop it from
hunting on September 16 2002 something
horrible happened near the Black Forest
in Germany a team of foundation
operatives had been placed in the area
to monitor a man from Freiburg who had
complained to the local police about a
clicking sound that had been following
him around for quite some time over the
course of four months of being unable to
escape the sound or the feeling that he
was being watched no matter where he
went he had become convinced that
someone was stalking him it was a
bizarre situation and he wasn't certain
how his stalker was making this
maddening sound but he believed his life
to be in danger concerned that this
could be the work of
scp-4975 the foundation operatives took
him into custody the police were given a
cover story claiming that the man was
experiencing a sense of paranoia as well
as auditory hallucinations as a result
of side effects from chemotherapy once
the foundation operatives explained to
the man that they meant him no harm
believed him about his fears and wished
to help he opened up about his
experiences he told the operatives that
in addition to the sound and the feeling
of something following him he had seen a
monstrous figure in the woods he had
kept the details to himself when
speaking to the police afraid they would
have him committed rather than listening
to him the operatives asked him to lead
them to the place where he had seen the
monster and he agreed the man led the
team to a densely wooded part of the
forest trees blocking out the sunlight
until their surroundings became as dark
as if it were the middle of the night as
they walked deeper and deeper into the
forest The Man became increasingly
anxious his breath came in short
strained gasps his eyes started from
tree to tree and he jumped at the
slightest sound of a twig snapping
beneath someone's foot or branches
rustling in a gust of wind suddenly
mid-stride he froze his eyes were wide
his face was white as a sheet with a
trembling hand he pointed toward a
nearby Tree in a voice so faint it was
almost a whisper he said
the operatives turn to look but saw
nothing there the man repeated yeah but
they couldn't see anything but the trees
the man stumbled back going weak at the
knees from Pure Terror and continued to
point at the empty space next to the
tree just as one operative was turning
to another to comment that their witness
must be out of his mind the man suddenly
collapsed onto the ground as if an
invisible powerful force had thrown him
down the man screamed for help
struggling against the Unseen attacker
as it slashed at his face in this chest
tearing through Fabric and skin blood
spraying across the forest floor two
officers Drew their weapons firing at
where they guessed the assailant might
be but their bullets ricocheted
uselessly off nearby tree trunks another
rush to the man on the ground grabbing
him under the arms and attempting to
pull him out of Harm's Way however the
man would not budge as the invisible
force held him in place shredding
through his stomach as it fought to keep
its prey afraid to rip open the stomach
wound any fur further the operatives
quickly ceased his attempts to move the
man instead he pulled out his weapon and
did the only merciful thing he could
think to do he shot the local man in the
head putting him out of his misery
before he was ripped to shreds the
operatives watched some in silent shock
some continuing to fire their weapons
some vomiting from sheer disgust as
strips of the Dead Man's flesh ripped
off of bone and disappeared one piece at
a time meanwhile thousands of miles away
surveillance footage of
scp-4975's containment site picked up
some peculiar activity in the creature's
cell it stopped rotating its neck which
it had done almost constantly since
being captured and stared at the corner
of its containment cell its eyes were
wide unblinking and it did not move a
muscle it stayed still for several
minutes until it eventually broke the
unsettling Stillness to eat greedily
gobbling down slices of meat there was
one problem though the creature had not
yet been fed that day all Foundation
operatives dispatched to Germany to
investigate
scp-4975 were recalled back to their
original sites and additional research
has been suspended until further notice
in light of this new information emotion
has been filed to reclassify the
creature as ketter and potentially
impossible to contain with the
foundation's current resources as
terrible as it is to admit this is one
monster the foundation has not yet found
a way to stop they may have it locked in
a cage but it can still hunt anyone
anywhere anytime it wants to wait a
second
be very very quiet what's that sound in
your room right now listen closely
tick tick do you hear it don't worry
it's probably just a clock or a kitchen
timer maybe it's just your imagination
tick tick tick whatever it is I'm sure
you'll be fine there's nothing dangerous
about a weird sound from time to time
you don't have anything to fear unless
it suddenly goes silent that's when
you're really in trouble when you know
scp-4975 is about to strike to devour
you alive wait stop hold your breath
don't make a single beep do you hear it
neither do I you hear their footsteps
coming down the halls or are those your
own can you even tell the difference you
can tell they're getting closer and you
can feel the hate the rage you turn
shaking and finally see them standing
right in front of you but in that moment
you might as well be looking into a
mirror and who knows perhaps you are you
just don't seem to remember having so
many Reflections have you ever ever
heard the saying you are Your Own Worst
Enemy of course it isn't usually meant
literally but what if it was what if you
had to fight a monster that was you all
of your flaws are reflected back at you
your strengths your weaknesses your
deepest fears with no way to escape
except a battle to the death either way
you're not making it out alive it's just
a matter of which version of you
survives but this isn't a thought
experiment no according to the findings
of the SCP Foundation it's very much a
reality there is a place where this
nightmare comes to life and it's known
as
scp-1919
scp-1919 is a hotel and converted
Mansion built in the early 20th century
from the outside it looks pretty much
like it did when it was first built and
it almost looks like a comfortable place
to stay if you ignore the Eastern side
of the building that has sunk partially
into the ground the inside however is a
different story where it's clear the
ravages of time have taken their toll
the floorboards and ceilings are rotting
collapsing in on themselves and the
rooms are filled with debris it's deadly
enough to explore the hotel for these
reasons alone but this is only the
beginning of the danger for a person
inside in order to determine just how
dangerous it is for either one person or
group to enter the structure the SCP
Foundation planned a series of research
Expeditions into the abandoned building
led by Foundation scientist Dr lemkowitz
the first expedition seemed relatively
normal at least it did at the start a 39
year old Caucasian d-class male known as
D7 was sent into the structure with a
camera and a communication system guided
remotely by Dr limkowitz or Dr Al and
another operative a former head of the
MTF Tau 11 youth hostiles who is
referred to in this file only as t11
when he arrived at the building the D7
was unable to get inside through the
front door or Windows after several
minutes of trial and error he was
finally able to get in through the
Western entrance Dr L picked up a
strange high-pitched Whistling noise
upon d7's entrance into the building but
it quickly faded away and was
disregarded by t11 D7 discovered a torn
painting a portrait of a young woman
with red hair next to the portrait
shallow scratches could be seen in the
wall the floor and parts of the ceiling
suddenly D7 ducked into a hiding place
alarm he and the other two operatives
listening to his audio feed could hear
heavy breathing and it didn't belonged
to D7 Dr L recommended that D7 evacuate
the building at this sign of another
entity inside but t11 overruled ordering
him to disregard that instruction and
continue his investigation D7 was told
to stay at a safe distance from whatever
was inside with him an attempt to
capture it on video D7 turned off his
flashlight in order to better hide but
t11 commanded that he turn it back on
whatever was caught in the beam of light
was difficult for the camera to see but
it threw D7 into a panic and he began to
run in the opposite direction when
prompted to explain what he saw D7
simply said it was me D7 ran through the
dark panting with fear and exertion
unable to see where his feet were
Landing he tripped over something and
came crashing onto the ground dropping
the video camera this allowed the
observing officers to finally see what
D7 was so frightened by and it became
clear just why D7 was so terrified a man
identical looking to D7 approached from
the end of the hallway making its way
towards the real D7 it was followed by
another man who also resembled D7 and
another all running toward the original
they all looked exactly like him with a
few notable differences they were
dressed in the same uniform with the
same build and the same feature but each
had something slightly off about him one
was missing eyelids another had
malformed hands and the third had its
lips fused together into a fleshy Mass
beneath its nose Dr L moved to cut the
camera feed but t11 demanded that it be
kept running D7 couldn't be seen by the
camera but the microphone picked up the
sounds of Flesh and cloth being torn
along with pained Panic screams as the
duplicates set upon after a moment the
screaming stopped two hours later the
camera was broken and the Expedition
brought to a troubling end this was the
foundation's first Glimpse at the
creatures inside of scp-1919 and it was
not pretty it did however allow them to
begin understanding the nature of the
building and what happens when a person
goes inside it appears that when a human
enters the hotel several humanoid
creatures manifest throughout the
building these creatures look like the
subject and are equipped with the same
clothing or items that the subject
brought inside with them though they are
nearly mirror images of the subject they
are always slightly warped in a variety
of ways these have included changes to
Limb and digit length joint Mobility
sealed nostrils lengthen Jaws hanging
loose and Limp missing eyelids and lips
that are fused together these creatures
are highly aggressive towards the
structure of the building itself as well
as to the subject that they resemble
they do not however attack each other
they appear to operate with a hive mind
exhibiting swarm intelligence like that
of an ant colony once they have been
spawned by the entrance of a new person
they will not stop until said person
either escapes the building or is killed
after the unfortunate end to the
Expedition the foundation prepped for a
second trip inside this time three men
were sent in with Dr L's guidance known
as D3 D4 and D9 video cameras were sewn
into their clothes to leave their hands
free and help avoid some of the issues
that came up during the first expedition
this small team was sent in with the
orders to terminate the remaining copies
of D7 and further examine the hotel's
interior upon opening the door to the
building they were immediately attacked
by one of d7's copies which D9 was able
to quickly dispatch by firing his weapon
at its head next after a great deal of
reluctance the three men entered the
building where they spotted something
unusual inside Dr Al was horrified when
the camera feed revealed 17 discarded
video cameras spread across the floor
they didn't have much time to react to
this new discovery however because two
doubles one mirroring D7 and another
mirroring D9 emerge from the wall and
began to attack Dr Al ordered the team
to take shelter then called the team of
guards outside of the hotel's perimeter
they were ordered to begin an immediate
full perimeter lockdown preventing the
doubles from leaving the hotel D3 D4 and
D9 attempted to make their way to a safe
corner of the building but found
themselves met with a murderous double
at every turn at this point Dr Al began
to hear an unusual sound over the
microphone feed a high-pitched wine like
that of a dentist drill the operatives
on the ground couldn't hear a thing but
on Dr L's end it was deafening as the
team proceeded deeper into the hotel
they became overcome with a strange
feeling of foreboding Dr Al ordered them
to turn on their flashlights but they
refused and begged Dr L to keep quiet
when prompted to explain D9 said she can
hear you the operatives stop responding
but their camera feeds caught a faint
glowing white light coming from beneath
the door the door opened and the light
flooded the camera making the images it
captured hard to decipher just a few
frames of a quick moving female
silhouette were captured before the
cameras cut to static the bodies of D3
D4 and D9 were never recovered nor were
their cameras a third expedition was
also sent into
scp-1919 but very little is known about
what occurred during it the video
transcript is highly classified and only
those present for its events or prove to
research
scp-1919 have access to it an update to
the scp-1919 file following Expedition 3
though indicates that new information
was revealed about the hotel during the
Excursion according to the file update
there is some kind of being at the
center of the location which is causing
all of the other creatures the doubles
to appear the only information available
about this being is the use of the word
her in the official Foundation log about
scp-1919 this seems to match up with the
last moments of the operatives in
Expedition 2. when they told Dr L that
she can hear you and the few frames of a
female figure that were captured by
their cameras nothing else is known that
has been made available to anyone
outside of very select few only the
original report exists and all other
copies of it have been destroyed the
foundation has undertaken special
containment procedures to make sure that
none of the entities from inside the
hotel Escape whether they are the evil
twins spawned by humans entering the
building or the mysterious female being
at the center of the entire disturbing
phenomenon the foundation is classified
scp-1919 as Euclid and a two kilometer
radius must be maintained around
scp-1919 with all roads leading to the
building are blocked or diverted so that
no vehicles are able to reach it this
perimeter is guarded by a set of at
least 40 armed and armored guards at any
given time as it has been determined
that the doubles spawn by 1919 are
equipped with whatever the human they
are copying has no one is allowed to
enter the hotel with body armor or
weapons of any kind anyone that
approaches the perimeter that is not a
part of an official Expedition team will
be immediately terminated no new
Expedition teams are allowed to enter
the building unless all doubles from the
previous Expedition have been
exterminated in the event that they
cannot be exterminated enough time must
elapse between Expeditions that the
previous doubles have starved to death
though they do not seem to feel hunger
the doubles do need to eat to survive
and will die when left alone for long
enough
scp-1919 has been sealed off from the
rest of the world so that no hapless
civilians can wander inside and find
themselves Torn to Pieces by warped
images of of themselves but that Comfort
turns cold when you realize that the SCP
Foundation still does not understand
what causes these doubles to spawn is it
scientific Supernatural or something
else no one can be certain even more
inexplicable is the entity at the center
of all of this an unknown female
presence capable of wrecking frightening
amounts of Violence by turning victims
own images against them what is the
purpose of these fun house mirror
nightmares who is she what is she and
what does she want currently the doubles
have shown no interest in leaving the
hotel except to attack Intruders and
thanks to that fact as well as the
reinforced perimeter outside these
copycats have not appeared outside of
the building itself but what happens if
they do Escape or if the entity that
controls them decides to make her home
elsewhere there is no telling what could
happen if this dark power is allowed to
move Beyond its current containment are
you prepared to fight a vision of self
Twisted almost beyond recognition
lunging after you with wide bulbous eyes
unnaturally long arms and a distended
jaw hanging down below its neck better
hope you never have to find out like any
other area in the United States the
State of Florida has a healthy share of
urban legends and local myths take for
example the legendary Swampy the
Region's Bigfoot equivalent a hulking
creature said to run amok in the state's
many swamps and Aquatic areas identified
by its strong repugnant odor and deep
guttural throat calls or the ghosts of
the Saint Augustine Lighthouse a Grizzly
tale revolving around two young girls
who drowned in the nearby sea while
their mother was working the lighthouse
too distracted to hear the cries of her
children as they were swallowed by the
current and returned to the brine it's
rumored that on Some Nights the twins
laughter and cries are heard from the
top of the lighthouse not scary enough
what about the Devil's Chair a seemingly
ordinary bench located in the town of
Cassadaga that was supposedly built by
the Devil Himself every night at
midnight the man in red returns to his
bench and if you sit beside him he'll
whisper Wicked horrible things into your
ear leaving you forever scarred and
haunted by The Experience just don't
leave a drink behind when you run off
the bench in Terror though another
Legend says that any unopened bottles
left on the bench will mysteriously be
opened and drained by the morning
torturing damn souls for eternity makes
you a thirsty guy we guess but to a
seasoned viewer of SCP explained urban
legends and local Oddities might seem a
bit mundane in comparison to the strange
inexplicable anomalies that the SCP
Foundation regularly researches and
contains after all the truth is almost
always Stranger Than Fiction and if an
actual anomaly gets picked up as an
urban legend the SCP Foundation is going
to do everything in their power to shut
it down cover it up and make the story a
little more digestible for the general
public that means relying on the same
tired tropes and cliches we've all heard
before cursed dolls bigfoot-like
creatures ghost hitchhikers we all know
them and as fun as they are the most
popular stories aren't always the most
unique or interesting and if you peer
deeper underneath the surface you can
always find kernels of Truth in the most
common place of Legends for example
what's commonly referred to as Bigfoot
or Sasquatch is actually
scp-1000 a super intelligent prehistoric
race of ape creatures known as The
Children of the Night who were
slaughtered by early humans and forced
to hide from the world in order to
preserve their species a cursed object
or location the foundation deals with
those all the time and stories of ghosts
are as commonplace in the anomalous
world as they are in the ordinary one
but what about an anomaly that utilizes
urban legends to further its own
nefarious goals one that's lifeblood is
localized to a single area today on SCP
explained we're going to be talking
about
scp-3640 an anomaly that capitalizes on
the interest and Intrigue those urban
legends generate specifically those in
the State of Florida we already talked
about the variety of weird and creepy
stories the state calls its own but what
else is Florida known for tourism
retirement communities beautiful summer
weather slightly crazy individuals
making news headlines for ridiculous
reasons how about Disney that's right
the State of Florida is known for Walt
Disney World the granddaddy of all theme
parks that brings in millions of tourist
dollars annually and the hub for some of
the most iconic characters and stories
in the world if you've ever been to
Disney World then you know about the
costume characters that roam the park
silent mascot costume Renditions of your
favorite TV and movie characters posing
for pictures and having fun with
children the park is practically
infested with them they seem inescapable
it's pretty understandable that some
people are unsettled by mascots they can
sometimes be downright creepy with those
unmoving expressions giant heads
unnatural movements and the faces of
familiar fictional characters in the
right context a mascot can be just as
scary as any horror movie monster or
urban legend could ever be here's a
situation for you you've just landed at
a Florida airport you're ready to go to
Disney World and enjoy a vacation after
you've been worked to exhaustion as a
junior researcher at the SCP Foundation
you want to get familiar with the state
but you're trying to cut down on your
phone usage after all you're on vacation
why not do things the old-fashioned way
and unplug from Electronics you spot a
brochure rack in the distance perfect a
paper hub for everything touristy in the
area among the hundreds of jet skiing
courses Beach information and mini golf
pamphlets one brochure in particular
stands out to you maybe it's your
background in the anomalous but you just
can't help yourself from picking up a
booklet on Florida's urban legends
knowing what's behind the curtain
working for the SCP Foundation really
makes these types of things more amusing
you've seen how the sausage was made and
it's a lot more terrifying than anything
known to the general public heck you
know for a fact that the organization
you work for has more than likely not
covered up most of the actual incidents
that inspired these local Legends
nonetheless you pick up the brochure
interested in the self-guided tour of
Florida's paranormal hot spots and
you're impressed to find that this
booklet has it all everything from skunk
Apes to a cursed doll it's all in here
you you chuckle and Tuck the pamphlet
underneath your arm but little do you
know you're about to experience
something more horrifying than any urban
legend could ever be you see if you paid
attention to your foundation briefings
before you left the state of Florida you
would know that any foundation Personnel
who encountered tourist brochure
pamphlets advertising self-guided
paranormal tours in Florida are to bring
said pamphlets to the foundation's
attention immediately mobile task force
Lambda 12 nicknamed Pest Control is
primed on demand for incidents related
to these brochures why because they're a
part of a phenomenon categorized by the
SCP Foundation as
scp-3640 but what is
scp-3640 why is something as innocuous
and fun as a paranormal travel brochure
an object of high interest for the SCP
Foundation well you someone who should
have maybe listened to the regional
briefing conference back at site 19
before you left on your vacation are
about to find out after perusing your
booklet and ruminating over the numerous
locations at your disposal you decide to
visit one after you get settled into
your hotel after all you're about to
experience a week of family-friendly fun
at the house of mouse why not partake in
a little just to get the blood
pumping a bit of living life on the edge
before the scariest thing you have to
deal with is a 10 bottle of water and a
three-hour waiting line to ride that
giant golf ball you drive all the way
out to the location the pamphlet
specified a bridge by the name of
Sunshine Skyway located right outside of
Tampa Bay visiting the bridge at night
might also get you a visit from a
mysterious and beautiful hitchhiker
woman who stands on the side of the
bridge and attempts to flag down cars if
you happen to take her in she'll begin
to weep growing progressively louder and
louder in her screaming and crying until
you reach the other side of the bridge
and when the driver turns back to ask
her what's wrong
the woman will have vanished Without a
Trace sounds like a fun time right maybe
you can find her heck maybe she's single
and interested in an enthusiastic and
kind Junior researcher of the SCP
Foundation you would never contain her
you promise having to raise your voice
over the sound of her weeping and crying
in the back seat of your car or maybe
not this vacation time outside of the
lab is making you think some strange
strange stuff whatever the case is you
want to see a ghost girl so you make
your way over to the Sunshine Skyway at
11 at night just like the pamphlet
specified the bridge is strangely empty
especially for what's usually a crowded
stretch of the road in fact now that you
realize it there's no one else here just
you your car the black night sky and the
sound of your humming engine well up the
road you go looking for this supposed
ghost hitchhiker the Skyway is quite the
drive and the longer you ride the less
safe you feel but you're you're fine
right it's a very popular Bridge driven
by thousands of people every day and
night it just so happens to be
completely empty at an ordinary time of
night and you can see the dark outline
of a figure in the distance standing in
the middle of the road as you drive
closer and closer you start to make out
the figure a bit more a circular head a
tall wide body and two more circles on
top of that round ball head closer a
little closer and wait is that there's
absolutely no way that's who you think
it is is that a Mickey Mouse costume
standing in the middle of the road it
apparently is and it seems like it's not
getting out of the way you honk your
horn but the overground rat doesn't
listen it's still standing there
unmoving you slow down you know what
Disney's legal team is capable of and
you are absolutely not going to jail for
running over Mickey Mouse so if he's not
moving out of the way you will instead
you try to maneuver around the
stationary mascot but suddenly out of
nowhere the thing leaps 15 feet into the
air and jumps onto your hood you scream
as the Mickey mascot skitters across the
roof of your car clawing and tearing at
the sunroof trying to get in you push
your foot on the gas as hard as you can
enough Force to propel Mickey from the
roof but it's not enough the mascot hits
the ground but immediately gets back up
and starts running after your car almost
instantaneously it catches up to your
car again and using strength to pry off
the door on the driver's side of the car
exposing you and causing you to lose
control of your vehicle you swerve
crashing into the side of the bridge and
banging your head off of the steering
wheel you never thought your life would
result in death by Mickey Mouse but the
rapidly approaching costume creature
seems to be saying otherwise the Mickey
creature bends down and uses both of its
gloved hands to grab you from your car
seat with enough Force to break the seat
belt and give you minor Whiplash from
being flung into the air so quickly this
is it you know it's over and you don't
even know what's going on or why this is
happening you're just another victim of
something you don't understand like the
countless dead you spent your life
researching or so you think just when
you assume that it's all over a shot
rings out from across the bridge when
you see a salvo of bullets pepper Mickey
Mouse's back carefully missing you with
impressively accurate Precision Mickey
drops you banging your head on the
concrete and runs towards with the
bullets are coming from several armored
heavily armed soldiers appear from the
side of the bridge and circle the mouse
they fire again but it has little effect
on the mascot once again he lunges
forward knocking a soldier off his feet
the mascot dashes off into the distance
leaving over the side of the bridge
though no splash is heard in the water
below you don't see the mascot Landing
or even escaping it's like he was never
there in the first place but at least
it's gone now and you have these unknown
soldiers to thank you for your weight is
that an SCP Foundation logo oh no their
Foundation task force operatives before
you're able to fully regain your senses
you can already hear the task force
Captain telling his underling to prep
you for amnestics in an interview the
soldier approaches you and you're
thankfully able to muster out a few
Choice words namely wait wait wait wait
I'm with you guys I'm a junior
researcher the captain pauses and laughs
to himself
what are the odds after you're processed
and taken to the nearest facility where
your identity as a card-carrying member
of the SCP Foundation is confirmed
you're let in on what exactly it was you
just saw back there as it turns out you
had an encounter with
scp-3640 an anomaly centering around a
set of travel brochures that advertise
self-guided tours of all of Florida's
paranormal hot spots if someone reads
the brochure and goes to a location at a
set time just like you did they'll be
preyed upon by a mysterious predatory
entity or set of entities that resembles
costumed mascot characters owned by the
Walt Disney Company Mickey Donald Goofy
the task force Captain explains that
they're all there and they're all over
the State of Florida hundreds of mascots
may be more they're fast dangerous and
the foundation knows remarkably little
about them including how they grow
reproduce or even consume their prey all
the known hotspot advertising the
pamphlet are routinely watched by
members of The Pest Control mobile task
force where operatives are authorized to
neutralize
scp-3640 entities with lethal Force
which is how that task force was able to
thankfully show up at the right moment
and save your life
scp-3640 only attack those who read the
brochures and haven't been seen being
hostile or hunting outside of the areas
specified by the pamphlet after you
recollect yourself and thank them the
captain hands you a file briefing on
scp-3640 gives you a Stern warning and
tells you to familiarize yourself with
it before you leave the facility what a
way to start your vacation you think
just when you thought you were able to
escape the daily horrors of working for
the foundation you stumble upon an
anomaly yourself but you undoubtedly
have more questions about
scp-3640 after all anyone would after
witnessing as weird and strange and
anomaly as that in the wild you asked
the captain why the foundation hasn't
captured an scp-3640 in especially if
they're so common in the Florida area he
sits down Sighs and explains the
foundation did try a while back it was a
standard d-class test held in the St
John's river the location of a supposed
river monster the d-class Personnel was
dropped off at the riverbank and told to
follow the instructions in the pamphlet
if they spotted a mascot they were to
shoot at it with a tranquilizer gun
after dredging through the river for a
few minutes and being distracted by a
neat looking alligator the d-class
eventually came head to head with none
other than Donald Duck himself who
emerged from a river and immediately
began moving towards the d-class the
d-class naturally freaked out completely
and ran away from the scene but Donald
was simply too fast just when he thought
he was safe the Donald mascot emerged
from the shadows and knocked the camera
and radio off of the d-class's head
there were sounds of a struggle but the
d-class never established contact again
however his subdermal tracking
transmitters continue to operate and
before they went offline completely they
luckily detected the location of the
d-class's body it was just outside of
the amusement park engaged by the
captain's story you ask him what
happened next surely the foundation
launched an assault on Epcot to figure
out what happened to the d-class right
the captain Grunts and tells you that
the rest is classified but you're not
satisfied you're refusing to move until
you figure out what happened to this
d-class the captain rolls his eyes and
perhaps feeling sorry for you decides to
tell you the rest of the story him and
his team were deployed just outside of
the Epcot Theme Park right next to a
one-story concrete Hut where the
d-class's location was tracked they were
equipped with heavy arms a net launcher
and a flamethrower all perfect weapons
for subduing these deadly mascots while
Lambda 12 was typically used to hunting
anomalous bugs and pests they figured
that hunting down Donald Duck and Minnie
Mouse was more or less the same thing
when you squint really hard and pretend
that they have wings the task force
broke into the Hut revealing it to be a
maintenance shed with a mysterious
trapdoor in the middle of the floor
underneath a ladder led to a tunnel
system similar to the ones built
underneath the Disney parks that the
employees used to get around from park
to park the team spotted several
dressing rooms and storage rooms all
empty and devoid of life after some
exploration the team followed a low
rumbling noise to a closed door they
slowly opened it revealing an abandoned
Boiler Room with a white mascot costume
at the foot of the boiler curled up
around an unknown object an operative
approached the costume and poked it with
a rifle identifying it as an empty Daisy
Duck costume the team examined it
further and found a human arm bone
inside the suit disgusting to be sure
but nothing the task force hadn't seen
before they turned over the suit to
examine the object it was curled around
discovering it to be a purple plastic
egg with an embryo inside scattered
across the floor were more eggshells the
squad gathered them as well as the bones
of the d-class in the costume to bring
it back to the facility suddenly the
task force heard noises in the distance
and assumed an attack formation they
noticed the floor of the entrance they
came in was now covered in dark fluid
and polyester stuffing the trail of
liquid exactly matched their path of
infiltration into the tunnel after
determining the situation to be safe the
squad carefully left the tunnel the way
they came bringing the costume and the
egg with them after several weeks the
egg hatched into a miniature stuffed
Donald Duck toy the foundation dissected
it discovering it to contain a plastic
endoskeleton and a rudimentary
polyester-stuffing muscular system
inside and that was everything the
captain had to say there was never any
other leads on the scp-3640 anomaly just
strangeness and inexplicable inability
to capture or understand the mascots you
think the captain for not only saving
you but explaining what was going on
before you left the facility to go back
to your regular foundationless vacation
you took another glance at the document
the captain handed to you on the back
page was a chilling letter dated from
1979 written to Florida Governor Reuben
Askew by the Walt Disney Company it read
as follows the Walt Disney Company
thanks you for your cooperation in this
matter regarding the unlicensed Walt
Disney character operators please pass
along the following information
collected by the outstanding men and
women of the city of Orlando's Police
Department to the Florida National Guard
if a character is spotted call to get
its attention and then rapidly flash
your flashlights at the costume if it
does not flinch fire on site aim at the
head if possible L same at the knees to
disable them and then finish them off
with headshots body shots have been
shown to lack Effectiveness deceased
characters are to be incinerated no
other means of disposal are advised we
are currently pursuing alternative legal
means of shutting down these unlicensed
operators and hope to achieve a
settlement within the end of the year
cordially yours the Walt Disney Company
take a brief moment to think back to
your younger years spending long
tiresome hours trapped in a classroom
waiting to hear the noise of that final
Bell of the day that sound meant Freedom
the end of another grueling six hours at
your desk and the chance to get back to
the warm sanctuary of home if you were
lucky you might not have had to go far
to get back to the Safety and Security
of being in your parents house living
close enough to the school would mean
you could easily walk home when the day
was through but your classmates while
they weren't all as lucky some of them
had miles to travel all the way across
town even fortunately though the school
bus would always be waiting outside at
the end of each day ready to take a
gaggle of rowdy kids back home and if
you were one of those kids that had to
take the bus you'll know that the trip
home after school was hardly a calm
drive paper planes and spitballs firing
from all directions wads of chewing gum
stuck to the undersides of sea other
kids all around you screaming and
yelling at the top of their lungs still
it could be worse right no trust us it
could be much much worse than you can
ever imagine what if one day the bus
that picked you up from school wasn't a
bus at all what if instead it was
scp-2086. picture this one day you get
put in detention at school maybe you
were disrupting a class or were caught
spraying graffiti on the outside wall of
the gem whatever the reason we're sure
you'll think it is unfair that you got
held back after school after everyone
else had already gone home but you do
your time until finally you're told you
can leave problem is your house is on
the other side of town and you've
already missed the bus you make your way
off the campus down the nearest Street
maybe there's a city bus you can catch
that'll get you back home as you stroll
away from your school you realize that
the nearest bus stop the first one on
the route home seems to be further away
than you remember it being must be just
the exhaustion of a long day getting the
better of you playing tricks on your
mind it's not like someone could move
the bus stop right finally reaching the
stop you notice lights coming down the
street after a few moments of waiting
quietly a late bus just like you hoped
for it pulls up to the next stop the
doors folding open to allow you on board
it's totally empty save for the driver
but straight away you notice there's
something odd about him he seems drained
of color his movements are weird more
like a puppet on strings than an actual
living breathing human being now that
you think about it if it wasn't for the
fact he was clearly moving driving the
bus you might assume that he was a
corpse then again maybe he just had a
long day too taking a seat you try not
to think about it and stare out of the
window in boredom you watch as the route
takes you past stop after stop all of
them empty just like the bus itself but
then something unexpected it happens
you've ridden the bus to and from school
so many times before that you can't help
but notice when for some reason it takes
a wrong turn looking out the window you
know you aren't mistaken the driver has
changed Direction instead of heading
towards the nearest Stop to home he's
taken the bus towards the furthest Edge
of Town desperately you try yelling at
him asking why he's taken the wrong turn
but the driver stays still as if he
can't even hear what you're saying
that's when you notice the smell you
didn't catch it before but now it's all
around you filling the air inside the
bus it's almost like the scent of
disinfectant the bus now smells the same
way a hospital does but that's not all
the more you breathe it in the more you
feel yourself starting to get woozy arms
and legs getting heavier everything
around you feels as if it's spinning
uncontrollably out of the windows you
can just about make up the sight of a
junkyard blurring in and out of focus
it's meant to be abandoned and yet
you're sure you can see movement massive
indeterminate shape shifting around in
the dark finally your vision goes dark
and you fall unconscious onto the floor
of the bus only you were never on the
bus to begin with no although you didn't
know it you were prey to something that
just looked like a bus
scp-2086 and now that it's caught you
you'll never see the light of day again
now scp-2086 doesn't just refer to a
single creature not by a long shot it is
the designation given to an entire
species of arthropods think lobsters
crabs and spiders or insects like
centipedes and millipedes only much
bigger to the untrained eye and
depending on when you look an instance
of scp-2086 will normally look like any
ordinary public transport vehicle of any
make and model or belonging to any
company or Transit Authority usually
though they look like regular old buses
at least while they're out foraging for
food when born an scp-2086 specimen will
grow to full juvenile size within a week
usually weighing 200 kilograms or less
full matured adult instances however can
weigh approximately 17
000 kilograms the adults are the ones
that go out foraging leaving the nest to
collect food to then bring back to the
Juvenile
scp-2086s and buy food we of course mean
humans while out on the roads matured
scp-2086 creatures are practically
identical to the auto vehicles that form
their bodies but the materials that this
disguise is made from the steel plastic
wood and glass they're all actually
comprised of specialized chitin the kind
of outer shell you'd find on most
arthropods but underneath that outer
shell that's where you'll find the Real
Horror within the main chamber beneath
the flooring of the bus's long inner
portion is stored the pulsing Beating
Heart of an s
scp-2086 specimen and we don't mean that
in a metaphorical sense if you were to
lift up the floorboards of one of these
bus-like creatures you'd see its heart
along with other vital organs like the
creature's brain and stomach what's more
the figure in the front seat that you
thought was a living breathing bus
driver actually isn't living or
breathing not anymore preserved in a
shell-like substance that the creature
is able to produce the driver is
actually a human corpse acting as a
Decoy for
scp-2086s from within the bus body
fibrous appendages reach up into the
corpse almost like incredibly thin hairs
the creature can then use the cadaver
essentially as a puppet a puppet with a
dead person's body that's how an
scp-2086 is able to move its driver
around making it appear more lifelike so
it can lure its prey aboard think of it
like the bioluminescent light that an
anglerfish uses to tempt unsuspecting
fish into their jaws same principle but
with a dramatically different result
when it comes to
scp-2086 but if you thought bus
creatures with internal organs under the
floor and Dead Meat Puppets in the
driver's seat weren't creepy enough
there's still much more to scp-2086s
than meets the eye for example when they
aren't out foraging the adult creatures
can unravel the roof of their
bust-shaped outer shell underneath is a
pair of wings large enough and strong
enough to carry their entire 7 000 kilos
of weight off the ground and up into the
air as For Eyes the headlights at the
front are in actual fact bioluminescent
Optical organs allowing the creatures to
see their prey even in the dark still
not horrifying enough well would knowing
about their legs help the wheels
underneath an scp-2086 specimen are also
capable of unraveling forming long gray
or black legs like those of a spider yes
these are bus creatures with wings and
multi-jointed legs these legs aren't
just big clumsy appendages either
compared with other arthropods scp-2086s
are able to use their limbs to perform
surprisingly intricate actions and finer
levels of manipulations for instance a
number of specimens have been observed
in the Wild by the SCP Foundation
Building shelters out of any materials
that they can find near their nesting
ground and where do they normally Nest
wherever there's plenty of scrap metal
and hardly any people to notice them
junkyards are the preferred habitats of
scp-2086s and where they will normally
establish their colonies while the
juveniles remain within the confines of
the colony adult scp-2086 specimens will
leave to collect humans although on
occasion the younger specimens have been
known to travel out from their nest and
rearrange or relocate signposts for bus
stops they then place them in a route
that leads them back towards their
nesting ground it's something worth
remembering if your nearest bus stop
ever seems to be a little further away
from the school than usual after
afterward the older specimens will
travel along the Route laid out by the
juvenile as CP 2086s picking up any
human passengers that they find waiting
at the relocated bus stops they have to
choose their moments wisely with people
boarding and disembarking from the bus
usually every few stops once an scp-2086
has as many humans on board as it can
carry with the certainty it won't lose
any of the upcoming stop it secretes a
substance similar to chloroform this
fills the inner chamber of the bus
causing that noxious smell like Hospital
disinfectant the chloroform-like
substance incapacitates all the
passengers on board rendering them
unconscious and readying them to be
taken back to the local
scp-2086 Colony once the adult scp-2086
has arrived at the junkyard the
juveniles will descend on it given their
much much smaller size they will climb
inside the mature specimen and forcibly
remove each and every human passenger it
is carrying within then comes the truly
nasty part feeding time each juvenile
scp-2086 will force their captive human
through an orifice that is located under
the front hood of their vehicle's shell
this sphincter a circular formation of
muscle that can expand and contract to
perform a bodily function is connected
to where the steering wheel is found on
an adult as cp2086 the younger creatures
will push their human prey through the
sphincter consuming them once this has
occurred those hairy appendages in the
driver's seat will then latch onto the
body of the now dead human piercing
through their skin winding up and around
their bones these are the same fibrous
hairs used to puppet the deceased corpse
and use it to lure others aboard the bus
but these appendages have another
function they're feeding tubes they will
drain every last drop of blood from the
scp-2086's prey until the body is little
more than a husk at which point the
tubes inject a saline solution directly
into the cadaver afterwards the inside
of the bus fills with that same
substance that preserves the corpse and
the process is complete as horrifying as
these creatures are one of the few
upsides of scp-2086 is is that they
don't live very long female specimens
will reproduce after eight days and
produce 20 Offspring after this point
each of these newborns reaches full
maturity and size in about a week on
average
scp-2086s live for 12 to 15 days another
net positive is because of their short
life spans an scp-2086 specimen doesn't
need to feed on a human more than once
as the nutrients it absorbs as a
juvenile are enough to sustain it
through adulthood once it has matured an
scp-2086 will go out into the nearest
city or town to forage for humans
providing food to the Next Generation
and so the cycle continues in the future
rather than taking the bus maybe it's
safer to walk it might mean the
difference between you making it home or
becoming food October 1980
SCP Foundation agent Cyril Novak and
Diana Fisher have been dispatched to
Austria's capital city Vienna to
investigate a series of mysterious
unexplained disappearances the
foundation was unsure if these events
were connected or even anomalous in
nature but they had reason to believe
that something was lurking beneath the
dark streets of Vienna a foundation
operative embedded in local law
enforcement informed the organization
that the authorities were panicking with
an emphasis on withholding information
about these disappearances from the
public and the media Novak and Fisher
conducted a survey of the city observing
the streets at night and keeping a
watchful eye on those who they deemed at
risk it was the undesirables of society
that were disappearing in droves
unsupervised children vagrants the
homeless all those that were indisposed
vulnerable and otherwise at risk of
being forgotten by a society were
potential victims according to several
sources these disappearances were take
taking place near access points to the
city's Subterranean infrastructure sewer
holes access tunnels storm drains
anywhere that led to the underground was
a potential risk site after a few days
of standard exploration and information
gathering around Vienna Novak and Fisher
moved on to interviews with law
enforcement and public officials using a
variety of cover stories they managed to
pry out A Deadly Secret from the mouth
of the police chief human remains had
been recovered near The Disappearance
sites the authorities opted to keep them
a secret from the public so as Not to
cause any Panic of a crazed serial
killer on the loose or Inspire fears of
something even worse lurking in the
city's underground the agencies the
three cadavers and alerted the
foundation that their mission had been
progressing as expected the bodies were
transported to humanoid containment site
282 in Graz Austria where they were
immediately examined by Dr Felix gotner
who performed an autopsy on the three
Corpses if the foundation was unsure
about anomalous involvement before they
were certain of it now the bodies were
in shambles mutilated beyond belief and
altered into an almost unrecognizable
State the mere stench of them caused
Personnel working with them to rush to
the bathroom and even those that could
typically keep their lunch down had a
difficult time examining them cadaver a
the cause of death was determined to be
from exsanguination or the extreme loss
of blood cadaver B was missing some
important fleshy components inside and
out some of which had been removed
entirely the cause of death was presumed
to be traumatic Cardiac Arrest the third
corpse could ever see was barely a body
instead it was a collection of Bones and
fluids the cause of death because of the
opaque conditions the cadaver was found
in was unknown these grisly deaths were
only the start of the foundation's
containment of this anomaly and are far
from the worst this file has to offer
this is SCP explained and today we're
going to be looking at
scp-3288 a collection of entities
otherwise known as The Aristocrats Dr
Gartner's analysis of the cadavers came
to a single conclusion a human could not
do this in fact he compared the
deceased's injuries and conditions with
the bodies of victims of hyena attacks
all sustained injuries weren't the
result of a blunt object sharpened blade
or a firearm but instead resulted from a
combination of teeth Claws and raw
physical strength the bodies had
abnormally large bite marks
approximately six times the size of
adult human teeth yet closer analysis
revealed that the indentations did in
fact coincide with human teeth whatever
did this possessed more than 60 teeth
unevenly distributed over six distinct
rows and required Jaws much larger than
those of ordinary humans there were
unique patterns among these markings
suggesting that it wasn't a single
entity that ravaged these corpses but
multiple there was no doubt about it
these deaths were anomalous in nature
the foundation issued a designation for
the entities responsible
scp-3288 and deployed mobile task force
Sigma 6 hellsingers a special unit
trained to capture deadly anomalies in
the field to bring
scp-3288 into Foundation custody the
operatives were tasked with patrolling
the leppoldstadt district the area where
most of the disappearances had occurred
secrecy as usual was a top priority and
members of the task force took Extra
Care to conduct their operations away
from the public eye as the purpose of
this mission was to contain the entities
for further study the operatives were
also ordered to refrain from lethal
force and to Target
scp-3288 with tracking darts to prevent
them from escaping the task force
divided up their assignments 12
operatives would Patrol the district and
search for any suspicious activity while
10 others would remain watch in
positions with unrestricted View use of
sewer holes and other underground access
areas for the first few hours things
were quiet but then two operatives
stationed near the Danube Canal made a
report to the rest of the team someone
near the canal was screaming not loudly
but in a muffled faint way the
operatives took initiatives and ran off
to investigate the matter themselves
requesting backup at the same time
reinforcements arrived less than three
minutes later but their teammates could
not be found moments later their bodies
were discovered by another operative
mangled beyond belief both operatives
were killed and alongside them was a
half-consumed corpse of a local civilian
as well one operative's body was
recovered from the canal while the other
was found after following a trail of
blood and fluids into an Alleyway but
despite the loss of life the mission was
still deemed a success before being
mauled by the scp-3288 instance the task
force operative managed to shoot the
entity with a tracking bullet a piece of
technology utilizing satellite location
which allowed the rest of the team to
follow the entity into the sewers the
tracking was working perfectly and the
entity was shown to be fleeing into
Vienna's sewer system until the signal
faded somewhere near the hofberg a
palace constructed centuries ago that
was once host to the Habsburg Dynasty
and presently serves as the seat of
power for the president of Austria the
team was confused as the fading nature
of the signal suggested that the
tracking bullet had been brought into a
location Far deeper than the Viennese
sewers were believed to accommodate the
mission moved onward into the depths of
the sewers in pursuit of
scp-3288 the following day the task
force had assembled a strategy for
mapping and exploring the Viennese sewer
system constructed in the mid-19th
century these sewers were part of a
larger network of subterranean tunnels
that include catacombs abandoned wine
cellars and underground Rivers without
proper planning and clear communication
death could be a very real possibility
and not even one caused by scp-3288 the
task force was divided into four teams
of five three to investigate the sewers
and one to remain on standby by
triangulating the location of the
tracked instance the foundation was able
to pinpoint the general area they would
need to explore by blocking off certain
exits and surface access points they
hope to minimize the possibility of the
entity's Escape or exposure to the
public while the primary objective
remain containing an scp-3288 instance
for scientific research lethal force was
authorized to be use in case of
emergencies the foundation valued the
lives of its trained soldiers and put
them above nearly anything still the
authorization of lethal Force spelled
impending doom for many experienced
Veterans of the task force they knew all
too well about what kind of entity they
were up against when the foundation
opted to skip the containment step and
prioritize getting out alive a team of
operatives reached their destination
safely but didn't discover anything of
significance during their track through
the sewers of Vienna at least not at
first after several hours of
Investigation they encountered human
skeletal remains while making their way
through way steep sewage one member of
the task force pointed out a loose brick
in the wall and then another did some
minutes later inspection of the area
found a number of loose-fitting bricks
that were able to be removed with ease
as if they were put there to hide
something when the entryway was fully
Unearthed it revealed a previously
unseen chamber whose walls were engraved
with a house of habsburg's coat of arms
operatives inside of the chamber
immediately knew what they were looking
at a family crypt of Royal bloodline
never uncovered before the Forgotten
atmosphere made them feel like they were
discovering a secret that they were
never supposed to know 24 sarcophagi
were found within the chamber and
historical records of the sewers and
surrounding area mentioned nothing about
a crypt beneath the palace multiple
statues were recovered from the chamber
as well depicting veiled women with
hushed Expressions holding a finger to
their lips almost as if to say that this
place was a royal secret and trespassing
had grave consequences get it grave
consequences no
okay moving on thought I would be funny
today the tombs themselves were
intricate decorated with ornate jewelry
and various expensive embellishments but
did not include placards markings or any
indication as to who was entombed within
when the operatives opened the
sarcophagi they were disgusted the
skeletal remains of over 300 bodies all
displaying severe and likely fatal birth
deformities the team was at a loss what
was the meaning of this room the
entrance had been destroyed some time
ago with stairs shattered and buried
among the Stone near the other side of
the row of tombs was a vault door coated
in bronze and bearing the coat of arms
of the habsburgs a seal written in Latin
was engraved beneath the coat translated
it read for purity of blood the task
force tried to pry the door open but it
wouldn't budge opening it would require
special equipment and after what they
had witnessed inside the sarcophagus
some members of the team were even
hesitant to continue trying the team was
ordered by the supervising team to hold
their location and await the arrival of
another team that would open the door
Foundation agents on the surface
organized a temporary evacuation of the
hofberg building the team waited for
backup throughout the night they made
attempts to open the vault but to no
avail once the surface had been properly
evacuated and an infiltration team
arrived inside the chamber to assist
with the vault door the gate was able to
be opened using oxygen fuel cutting
torches over a period of two hours once
opened the team was met with an ominous
descending staircase leading to an
unknown dark location underneath the
palace an eight-man Squad heavily armed
and equipped with recording devices
ventured down the staircase radio
Transmissions from the squad grew
increasingly faint over time when they
reached the estimated 65 meter Mark
underground their Communications arrays
were barely audible at the bottom of the
stairwell was an ornate foyer instead of
decaying Graystone walls and oceans
sewage there were marble floors with
felted carpets and white painted walls
and ceilings this chamber was found to
be architecturally identical to a
certain wing of the hofberg palace
furthermore the chamber was clearly
built in the 18th century as many
aesthetic choices popular during that
era were clearly present much like the
crept there were sculptures and statues
but this time there were also columns
paintings and tattered tapestries some
of the operatives admiring the beauty of
the room overlooked that on every piece
of art and in all depictions of the
human form were defaced and altered the
air was rancid with operatives
describing the odor as similar to rotten
meat and stale sweat the floor and walls
were discolored with what appeared to be
dried old blood regardless they moved
forward in between the space equivalent
of the hofberg Imperial library was a
laboratory not found in the palace above
an operative collected numerous
documents relating to Alchemy biology
and the Occult as well as a journal of
transactions contracts and private
writings these documents were delivered
to above personnel and were later
translated by Foundation Personnel All
Along The Chamber were human remains
decomposing and strewn around the palace
suddenly a bell told and the music of a
pipe organ began playing discordantly
for over three minutes operatives hid
themselves and deactivated their
flashlights some hiding behind the
curtains of a large Opera Hall and
others behind large instruments they
heard Footsteps in the distance minutes
later a group of figures emerged into
the palace Hall these entities the
foundation had classified as
scp-3288 were now fully visible their
outfits were typical of the 18th century
containing deep shades of red that
contrasted with their stark white skin
porcelain masquerade masks and powdered
wigs their bodies were monstrous with
arms dragging across the floor uneven
faces long fingers some possessing more
than 10 of and hunched backs a pair of
smaller instances entered behind the
horde of others had one blew a rusted
trumpet while the other held a banner
depicting the Habsburg Crest the
trumpeter began speaking but its words
were unintelligible and raw guttural
moans they ran out of the way their
stunted legs causing them to trip across
the floor there were now over several
hundred scp-3288 instances inside the
ballroom multiple operatives activated
silent distress calls requesting backup
to deal with the massive entities they
would have to contain these instances
bowed their heads and another mass of
footsteps were heard as a group of
scp-3288 instances carried a morbidly
obese instance atop a throne it wore a
cape a red veil in place of a mask and a
crown too small for its head it was
evident that this was their leader a
large cauldron was placed before the
king a small instance climbed Atop The
King's shoulder and lift lifted the
entity's veil to speak to it The
Cauldron was uncovered and the King
lurched forward grabbing the tub and
pouring its contents down its massive
mouth some of the king's disgusting
meals spilled from its mouth revealing a
small human child with severe
deformities the scp-3288 instances
roared an Applause and began to feast
all while the cacophony of noise brought
on by the various instruments inside the
ballroom raged on an operative hiding
behind a harpsichord was discovered by
an scp-3288 instance and quickly
consumed by it in The Feeding Frenzy the
entities were engaged in still barely
alive before being entirely digested by
The Entity the consumed task force
operative triggered an explosive device
from within the entity's stomach with a
look of immediate discomfort The Entity
suddenly exploded taking out several
other nearby 3288 instances with the
blast the entities were distraught and
while they were distracted the task
force leapt into action and rendered the
remaining scp-3288 instances not killed
by the explosion unconscious using
devices loaded with a gas as Foundation
reinforcements arrived the surviving
scp-3288 entities were contained and
moved to site-282 including the massive
King whose body was transported using a
specialized crane after the removal of
all remaining entities the palace was
filled with cement and reburied with the
foundation making sure that no one would
ever Discover it again after the King
was contained Foundation Personnel were
shocked to discover that the entity
could speak in an interview with the
hulking monstrosity it revealed that its
name was Maximilian the great a
patriarch of the house Habsburg the
entity's eyesight was severely damaged
from centuries of living underground and
the foundation was able to get the king
to comply by shining powerful lights in
its eyes The Entity was delusional
believing itself still to be inside the
palace and referring to the doctor as
nothing more than mere
which it wanted to consume when the
doctor was able to convince the king
that he too was Noble blood which the
king believed due to his unstable mental
state The Entity uttered a chilling
statement we are of this shame Noble
blood but some are more noble than
others our bloodline is pure
untainted by Outsiders they do not eat
human they eat pigeons we eat
undesirables beat of our life
undeserving of life that is the nature
of nobility but else would be the point
DNA testing revealed that the King was
in fact descended from the house of
habsburgs as all scp-3288 instances were
but what are the journal entries
discovered inside the palace after
translation the foundation found that
they contained the writings of Leopold
the first a holy Roman Emperor and
member of the Habsburg house in the
early 1700s his writings detailed his
desire to claim power over the royal
family as well as his fears of an
increased number of inbred deformed
members of the Habsburg house Leopold
details meeting a woman of Unknown
Origin who promised him that his family
name could live forever she taught him
Arcane knowledge involving
experimentations of the flesh small
animals and eventually humans were
subject to Leopold's disgusting Unholy
experiments even his mystical teacher
became disgusted with what her tutelage
had wrought as payment she demanded that
Leopold ceases Reign deliver his land
and wealth to Common People and Destroy
his various deeds and titles Leopold
refused and had the woman burned at the
stake for witchcraft eventually
Leopold's experiments to make his
bloodline Perpetual resulted in the
creation of
scp-3288 years of inclusive family ties
mutated over one another generation
after generation until a horde of
scp-3288 living underneath the palace
and feasting on a diet of human meat
were created for years the surface
habsburgs catered to scp-3288's depraved
and disgusting needs providing them with
a slew of humans to Feast on and a
lavish lifestyle akin to the one lived
by the nobility above one other document
revealed to the foundation that there
were multiple hives of scp-3288 existing
throughout Europe most were discovered
and neutralized but the original writing
was heavily damaged by mold meaning that
there were some locations the foundation
was unable to uncover colonies of
scp-3288 instances buried underground
snatching humans without any care
mutating their own deformities and
living horribly unable to be stopped a
captured scp-3288 instance in Germany
revealed that there was another entity
similar to the king in Authority by the
name of the empress it had this to say
to the foundation upon being contained
the meek did we get this strong the Doom
will beget The Chosen don't you see the
greedy that devours the charitable and
the merciles will ravage the peaceful we
will make the world as perfect as us we
will all be Aristocrats in the end and
our Dynasty will never die happy
birthday it's your day to enjoy however
you want with lots of gifts and sweets
and look a little friend is here to help
you celebrate it's the birthday monkey
and he has a song to sing dating back to
the 1940s
scp-983 is one of the most harmless
looking objects in the SCP foundation's
possession it's an old-fashioned
mechanical monkey a common wind-up toy
from the old days it's dressed rest in
the sharp little vest and holds a tiny
bell and striking rod for making music
it seems to be a simple toy the kind
that would annoy a tired parent as it
plays its Little tune over and over but
nothing more but this is no ordinary
wind-up toy
scp-983 is capable of sounds and even
speech that doesn't seem to match up
with its design and an investigation
reveals it doesn't have any signs as to
how it was constructed no screws seams
or markings that would be common on a
toy and no voice box or other mechanical
feature that would allow for speech but
despite these Oddities it seems to be a
normal toy that can be handled safely
and played with on every day but one
that is because
scp-983 has a second purpose and on one
special day it has a gift for its
Handler it can be a gift of Joy or a
gift of Terror nicknamed The Birthday
monkey
scp-983 activates when it is handled by
someone within the 24-hour period of
their birthday it seems to be able to
tell when this period of time happens
automatically and as soon as it becomes
aware a series of surprises begin to
surface for the lucky or unlucky Handler
it starts with a little leap as soon as
scp-983 becomes aware of the birthday
boy or girl it'll do a Charming little
backflip it'll then lift its Bell and
start singing the same song a ring a
ding ding it's your birthday to this day
the foundation has not been able to
figure out exactly where this voice
comes from and it follows this by
ringing its Bell the tone of the Bell
varies widely in ways that the
instrument should not be able to create
ranging from low tones to painfully
high-pitched tones and that's where the
horror Begins the birthday monkey
doesn't just want to sing a song it
wants to play a game the song will
repeat every three to four seconds
marked by rings of the bell and for
every Ring Of The Bell the birthday boy
or girl will age a year continuing until
they die of old age or win the game but
how does one win the game before it's
too late no one is sure but studies of
this strange toy in action indicate that
it involves singing along and timing it
correctly it's probably a little hard to
do that while aging to death in seconds
but no one said scps play fair but in
the event that someone actually does
manage to survive the Birthday monkeys
game it has a prize for them when the
sing-along is complete
scp-983 will let out an enthusiastic
shout of birthday ring its Bell and drop
a single Gumdrop from its Bell but which
Gumdrop depends on just how well the
birthday victim did a perfect sing-along
will result in a clear candy that seems
to Glow if it's a little less than
perfect the candy won't glow but it'll
work the same and both candies have a
very valuable property when eaten the
candy will immediately reverse any Age
Loss during the game but does the
Perfect Score give another prize studies
of the rare glowing candy led the
foundation to believe that it may also
provide a bonus effect making the person
who eats it younger and giving them a
longer lifespan or Better Health but
this is largely guesswork because the
candy is produced so rarely and the
effects would only become clear after
years or Decades of study but not all
candies are to be eaten many candies
have different appearance and quality
have been produced all can be eaten
safely except the black ones which
represent a failed sing-along the
effects of this candy were discovered
the hard way because the first time
scp-983 was activated it was Act
activated in the wild before the
foundation had secured it and everyone
knows that an SCP in the wild can be a
terrible thing it was at a local flea
market when the buyer noticed the Sharp
Dressed little monkey the buyer having a
friend who loved monkeys thought this
would be a perfect gift the seller was
not as enthusiastic and warned the buyer
that it shouldn't be handled or even
seen by anyone on their birthday but
even the seller didn't really believe
this saying that it might have just been
an old legend that had been passed down
for years it didn't dissuade the buyer
and off the monkey went to its new home
scp-983 was activated at an office party
where the monkey was presented as a gift
the guest of honor loved it at first
until it started singing the staff
noticed that as the monkey kept singing
their co-worker became more and more
upset the monkey kept singing and he
started to search for a way to turn it
off but there was no button or any other
way to deactivate it and that's when the
co-workers notice something disturbing
the honoree seemed to be getting weaker
and weaker and there were even streaks
of gray appearing in his hair his skin
was getting more wrinkled than weathered
soon his hair was entirely gray and he
simply returned the monkey to where it
was as it continued to sing he seemed to
give up begged for someone to turn it
off and waited to expire by the time the
foundation arrived on the scene it was
already too late there was nothing left
of the birthday boy but a desiccated
skeletal corpse the monkey had been able
to sing at least 30 more verses and no
one had truly understood what was going
on they reacted with confusion and
inaction unable to contain the monkey's
Dangerous Game even the foundation
didn't understand
scp-983 at first so they let the object
continue singing until the body degraded
into a simple skeleton that's when the
monkey exclaimed its finishing phrase
and released a single black Gumdrop
while no one ate the Gumdrop the
foundation observed that it seemed to
hypnotize people around it as if it was
compelling them to do something what is
lurking within the black gumdrops and do
they want to be consumed the birthday
monkey was taken into SCP custody and it
became clear that it was harmless to
everyone for 364 days of the year the
foundation wanted to understand more
about this odd toy so they fell back on
their best resource for testing d-class
Personnel who got the chance to show off
their singing skills with much higher
Stakes than your average round of
karaoke most of the tests were routine
with controlled activation showing how
to deactivate the monkey or providing up
close studies of its devastating effects
but one test hinted that this specimen
could be more dangerous than thought few
people volunteer for testing duty at the
SCP Foundation but that wasn't the case
for one now classified subject her
birthday was approaching and she
surprisingly volunteered for the test
that could only be done on your birthday
she had an oddly upbeat attitude and
seemed oddly excited about her birthday
the test was approved and she was given
limited information she was given the
monkey as a wrapped gift told it would
sing and encouraged to sing along for a
video but her reaction indicated she
might know more than expected as soon as
the gift was unwrapped the SCP began
singing after missing the first verse
the subject picked up the words and
started to sing along not just
competently but perfectly and
enthusiastically soon enough she started
aging rapidly but didn't seem distressed
by this at all she maintained her high
level of enthusiasm even as the monkey
sang for over 40 verses and aged her
over 40 years she seemed unaware of
these drastic changes and never missed a
beat of the song Until the monkey issued
its finishing exclamation and now it was
time for her prize the Gumdrop had fell
from the Bell was a new one completely
white and almost shockingly bright it
glowed and the subject was immediately
Enchanted by it even the attending
scientists and staff couldn't help but
comment on how impressive it was the
subject was allowed to consume it to see
its effects and was monitored for an
hour afterward when nothing unusual
happened besides the reversal of the
Aging the subject was excused to return
to her quarters and that's when things
took a shocking turn in an effect never
seen before the subject suddenly
exploded with a brilliant burst of white
light whatever this light was it was
strong enough to knock out all the
cameras in the vicinity everyone in
their presence was temporarily blinded
with it taking five minutes for their
eyesight to return no long-term ill
effects were shown but the staff that
entered the room after the blast noticed
that the odd glow remained in the room
and that wasn't the only odd thing the
test subject was nowhere to be found and
has never been seen again the foundation
is on high alert for this test subject
but she seems to be staying below the
radar if she's even human at all anymore
while there is no physical sign of her
the foundation has observed odd patterns
of electromagnetic activity in the area
and is following reports of light
fixtures needing to be replaced it was
clear that
scp-983 was much more unpredictable than
expected while still classified as safe
the foundation is keeping scp-983 under
tighter lock and key these days all
technicians who handle it are carefully
vetted to ensure that they are nowhere
near their birthday in case of
accidental exposure the foundation has
prepared emergency kits with detailed
instructions for how to complete the
Birthday monkeys deadly sing-along game
but as with all things the foundation is
prepared for anything in the event of a
failure The Remains will be disposed of
by vetted staff any candies produced are
to be taken into custody by the
foundation and studied for unusual
properties but are not to be consumed
without full containment procedures and
approval from senior staff The Only
Exception is d-class testing but even in
those cases one rule remains intact no
one is ever to consume the black candies
and caution is encouraged around the
birthday monkey lest you wind up in a
sing-along for your life from the Garden
of Eden to the top corner of your
English teacher's desk apples have
played an equal role in history's most
remarkable days and also its most
mundane the sounds of teeth snapping
through the skin sinking into flesh and
spitting out seeds and go through space
forever and onward and for most of our
Earthly hours consumed by appetite it
has been documented to be a lopsided
relationship between these two things
man and apple men getting the sweet
taste and abundant nutrients Apple's
getting nothing but pain and stomach
acids but this story is not found in our
history buried in the lawful patterns of
predator and prey we stumble upon an
irregularity an inversion an instance of
Apple's biting back
scp-4608 also known as apple seed was a
60-acre apple orchard containing over 22
000 trees located just on the outskirts
of Milan Indiana a town so small it
strains your eyes as you squint to find
it with a microscope hovering just over
a map and to see what was actually
happening within the Curious fringes of
society took even greater exploration
not just of the eyes but also of the
mind because what would eventually be
scene would not so easily be
comprehended physical senses are just
the surface and we need to go deeper Our
Story begins with a great Logging
Company looking to take ownership of the
most fertile land they could find in the
Great Lakes region ideally land that
overproduces Conifer growth so that the
return on their investment would be
plentiful and Perpetual these
lumberjacked men knew what they wanted
beneath their red flannel shirts and
muddy boots was a deep intelligence and
understanding of nature their process of
assessing the land's value was
meticulously calculated they knew the
soil both by the experience of their
calloused hands and the literature of
their study they tracked various bird
species migration patterns in the area
to assess what kind of seeds they'd be
carrying and contributing to soil by way
of their stool they understood the local
laws relating to clear cutting and
conservation and how both would affect
their profit margins this is all to say
it wasn't just a speculative purchase
this was planned through and through and
dwelled on and yet even then with
scrupulous eyes and careful crew they
miss the warning signs
scp-4608 checked all their boxes and
then some what could go wrong and so
they acquired the land unwittingly
purchasing the Peril that came with it
on the first day of owning the property
one crew member noticed the branches did
not Sway in the same direction as the
wind blew he noticed the leaves didn't
float down in agreement with their
feathery weight but rather crashed to
the soil like two-dimensional anvils and
grand pianos The Roots were not ones who
simply trip over instead it seemed as if
they stuck their leg out to trip you
when Birds perched themselves up high
and sang their songs their Cadence
carried all the eeriness of an SOS with
all this said he was happy to have
acquired the land and having already
picked up and moved his family from the
west coast to now live and work out in
Milan Indiana he decided it was best to
look past his concerns after all was the
first day on the new site and excitement
was in the air but with it also an
amorphous anxious energy during the
first logging Expedition within
scp-4608 this same member of the crew
hiked the grounds to better familiarize
himself with the environment he'd be
working on hoping that if he managed the
land properly and extracted the lumber
as efficiently as his late father did he
would be able to help build the business
and give his children the life he always
promised them he brought with him his
notepad and took detailed records of his
surroundings he figured to achieve his
goals and sustain long-term yields he'd
have to cooperate with his environment
but he never questioned if his
environment wanted to cooperate with him
would this question have changed the
course of action or is brooding on the
preference of plants and empty gesture
best left for hippies at Woodstock
either way the orchard let it be known
how it felt about a collaboration when
hours later the man was found dead it
was first believed by his co-workers to
be a result of a safety equipment
malfunction maybe it was a simple matter
of thinking the skitter was in park when
it was really in neutral maybe the
knuckle boom loader went on the fritz
how it does when the humidity ramps up
maybe Machinery really wants to blame in
which case you call it a fluke and ask
no more after all there's only so many
questions you can ask a robot but
initial belief is a Fickle thing and it
wasn't long until first impressions were
called into question by the courts of
critical thinking the questions of the
crew however only rang briefly because
shortly after the first death fell a
sequence of others in a matter of days
all the remaining crew members were
declared dead or missing a word reserved
for search party still clinging to Hope
a hot potato they would have been wise
to abandon for while it was hope that
brought these search parties together it
was hope that sent them off never to be
seen again the foundation was then
alerted to the occurrences surrounding
scp-4608 by police reports accompanied
by a photograph a photograph of an
scp-4608-1 an organism consisting of
unidentified plant-like muscular
structures and a periderm resembling
those found on common Hardwoods from the
photograph alone it was clear that this
three meter tall organism was capable of
committing the violence recently endured
forceful in its demeanor aggressive in
its presence and territorial in its
perception the photograph of
scp-4608-1 led to an even bigger
question is this plant-like creature
grown by nature or sown by man after
extensive research by the foundation
records were retrieved that indicate the
entirety of the 60-acre land was sewn
into Life by John Chapman in 1826.
Chapman was the type of man you could
mistake for a scarecrow both for reasons
of preferred Garb and Body Language he
was treated as such too his personal
space was respected maybe too much he
spent his life alone only accompanied
and comforted by the things he planted
he made retain these Acres all by
himself until his eventual death in 1845
and it's then that it's believed
scp-4608 became unstable reassigning its
objective from Comfort to chaos when the
newspaper came out the next Sunday John
Chapman's obituary painted him as a
priest of the Allen County church but
was this just the art of Illusion for as
far as we know no records of a chapel or
congregation exist a quiet choir indeed
come to think of it it seems that
everything within this 60-acre Orchard
was destined to be silenced one way or
another by violent force or even by
conscious decision-making see while the
SCP Foundation has had a long track
record of subduing anomalies by methods
of capture and containment not all
things are suited for locks and chains
scp-4608 is better covered with a story
than a tar a fruitless field that once
produced at an unmanageable pace is now
rendered incapable
growth most will think it's due to a
toxic spell in Truth The Spill wasn't
that of chemicals on soil but rather
corpses on crops a week after receiving
the photograph of 4608-1 site 81 sent a
three-man investigation team into Milan
their Adventure was equally abrupt a
story with no reportable beginning or
middle but simply a predictable end
after four days of no communication the
foundation presumed the three agents no
different than their steak dinner dead
meat and only then after the
foundation's failure to solve the case
was it understood that what we were to
be looking for wasn't people at all but
rather answers to more nebulous
questions what's really happening here
and why is this happening following the
loss of communication with the
investigation team site-81 dispatched a
high-risk Response Team Mobile Strike
Force Bravo 7 AKA Hometown Heroes these
men had all the makings of Heroes and
they were determined to prove themselves
worthy of the time while the alpha Squad
moved north towards the incident site
beta Squad headed east and Gamma Squad
hurried West the crews covering all
directions of the compass but South a
coincidentally symbolic gesture as if to
say we will not be taken down the
mission was simple in theory find out
what happened to the previous team and
why but alas missions never are as easy
as their objective statement reads in
practice some might even call them
impossible as Alpha neared the incident
site they noticed the Shadows on the
ground beneath them did not resemble the
shape of the leaves in the canopy above
they heard small drops of liquid tap tap
tap on their helmets yet it wasn't
raining was it Alpha One ran his finger
across the top of his helmet and then
examined the residue left on his skin it
was raining just not water oh God upon
looking up he witnessed the reasons for
both irregularities bodies hung from
branches by their intestines casting
shadow puppets with their lifeless limbs
blood drip down like a leaky faucet what
did this but before he could even Ponder
the answer he heard a loud shriek from
his radio so loud that the radio itself
vibrated shaking its way loose from his
hand and falling to the dirt he bent
down and picked it up and this time
gripped tighter as if to tell whoever
was responsible for that noise that they
will not get away that easily he and his
crew followed this sound like a game of
Marco Polo blind to what may be a head
they extended their guns and pointed
them into the distant Tree Line like
zombie arms reaching outward in the pool
towards the Resonance of Polo a small
comfort in a giant game of distress as
they press forward Alpha Squad proceeded
past all signs that pointed them back
stepping over dead bodies like puddles
on a rainy day soon they found
themselves crouching down next to human
remains attending brief and hurried
funerals for all their closest comrades
torn between staying to pay respect and
marching along to earn it the chest
cavities of the Fallen had been ripped
open and filled with apples a grim
foresight into what they were up against
but nothing they could have ever
imagined would prepare them for what
they were about to see and they wouldn't
have to wait long another loud shriek
from alpha one's radio it shot free from
his grip and landed again in the dirt
the squad tried to ignore the
metaphorical implications of this
reoccurrence quickly picking up the
radio and trucking it off as if the
five-second rule applied equally to
communication systems as candy bars they
pressed forward maybe out of Bravery
maybe out of Shame of going back and
while moving through the trees they
began to notice something alarming
etched on their bark what was it there
were unnaturally deep grooves on the
base of almost every one of the trees
but what exactly were they from
scratches from an animal or beast
infection Decay their eyes Drew closer
but proximity brought them no Clarity
these sigils and symbols could be dated
back to a cult Norse religion but in
that moment they were incomprehensible
to the men yet the message even if
misinterpreted was very clear beware
another shrieking cry over the radio the
bullets the bullets aren't they're not
working they can't they can't penetrate
the bark the grass is no Greener over on
the east side of the orchard where beta
Squad gets lunged at by an
scp-4608-1 their defenses are futile but
they fight nonetheless sending rounds to
the attacker's chests leading
nothing if scp-4608 had a health meter
it wouldn't have budged in the slightest
understanding the negligible impact
their efforts and assessing their
injuries beta Squad scurries to retreat
to an abandoned Chapel taking a brief
Refuge from war only later to be named
quickly they barricade the door in the
chapel beta 9 tends to Beta 6's wounds
who is in the worst shape of them all
cut bloody and beaten as he lays there
grimacing he shines his flashlight up
and down the Chapel's walls until he
finds a reason to stop and holds it
steady illuminated is an assortment of
human skulls and if this wasn't dramatic
enough he then spotted apple seeds
embedded in beta 6's wounds apple seeds
that were starting to sprout beta 9 gave
him to him straight This is Gonna Hurt
he drew his knife from his belt and
lowered it into his comrades wounds beta
9 dug into flesh and Bone picking the
seeds out one by one beta 6's scream
shook the Chapel's stained glass windows
as beta1 stood guard he saw blur
as if life had suddenly been turned up
to three times speed he spun around in a
circle to try and keep his eyes on it
but as his vision refocused he saw beta
9 was now dead he then shifted his gaze
to Beta 6 who was looking less and less
Human by the second branches began
sprouting out of his body like an
all-consuming magic beanstalk out of his
chest out of his eyes out of his mouth
and when there were no more orifices to
exit his body exploded making way for
the new form that had overtaken him the
barrage of branches broke through the
windows only two of them were lucky to
be on the outskirts of inertia outside
Gamma 1 was on his knees thanking his
dead comrade for the grenade he stole
from his back pocket I could always
count on you to have my back even in
death one hand holding a grenade and the
other on his radio Gamma 1 called off
Alpha 7 Alpha 7 request for backup
rescinded go grab a burger I'll take it
from here Gamma 1 slowly glanced up and
locked dice with
scp-4608-2 a large apple tree with 13
human faces embedded into it a perennial
plant with great Powers a gymnosperm
that had found a voice blood poured from
scp-4608-2's empty eye sockets Gamma 1
smirks get some eye drops sicko he
crawled over to the Beast the faces
began yelling at him in Indescribable
tongues let me refer you to a speech
therapist he jokes as he pulls the pin
of the grenade and throws it towards the
largest of the 13 mouths
scp-4608-2 chokes on the grenade forcing
it to inhale deeply the strength of its
lungs pulling Gamma 1 toward it and
sucking him in the grenade goes off
scp-4608-2 explodes the surrounding
trees scream and combust the orchard
Goes Up in Flames the bodies of the
Fallen are given an appropriate
cremation gamma one's radio lays face up
in the dirt The Voice rattles it awake
it's Alpha 7 gamma 1. gamma one are you
there can you hear me please please it's
Alpha seven please Gamma 1 on October 16
1947 Gamma 1 was recovered by the Allen
County Fire Department unconscious and
suffering from exhaustion and smoke
inhalation the site-81 concealment team
took control of the situation and
quarantined the area using the cover
story of a toxic chemical Hazard the
members of MTF Bravo 7 were postiniously
awarded the foundation star for their
efforts during the neutralization of
scp-4608 and so the one question that
remains is how how did
scp-4608-1 become so dangerous and how
did its danger slip by for so many years
is its volatility by Nature design or
consequence could it be that the
foundation failed to understand the
complexity of this creation during
Chapman's lifetime there were no
accidents or fatalities coming from
scp-4608 yet there is no reason to
believe that
scp-4608-1 wasn't always capable of harm
maybe it always was capable of mass
murders but simply had no reason to kill
what if the Logging Company never step
foot on that land never brought out
their sharp blades and heavy machinery
what if this perilous Orchard was in
fact docile but provoked what if the
proverbial tree only falls in the woods
when we force our philosophy on it
though
scp-4608-2 spoke an unidentifiable
sounds the noises were always recognized
and recorded as language it spoke with
intent even if misunderstood what it
screamed is still unclear were they
pleased for help or messages of hate and
would one even be worse than the other
John Chapman might argue when facing
heavy machinery and trained artillery
would raising your voice even be a moral
decision at all is fight or flight
imbued not just in blood but also in
bark the devil on your shoulder your
guardian angel these are expressions
that we've all heard countless times of
course they're not supposed to be taken
literally none of us have a Heavenly
Spirit looking over us and protecting us
from harm in the same way that nobody
really has a little red skinned imp
Whispering encouragement to commit
atrocious deeds in someone's ear their
metaphors Guardian Angel refers to any
instance of seemingly divine
intervention but is more often a
coincidence that ends up benefiting a
person when they need it most and the
devil on your shoulder that's Temptation
the little voice in the back of your
head that sometimes eggs you on to do
something you know you shouldn't but
what if there was a being that was both
a demonic malicious creature that also
acted as a guardian for someone unable
to protect themselves is it even
possible for a being to be both angel
and devil and who out there could ever
qualify for such holy and hellish
protection hombre Rouge was once a
fairly normal place to live a small
Louisiana Town in one of the smallest of
these 50 United States its name was
derived from the French language
translating to Red Shadow an ominous
name for a Township that was otherwise
so uninteresting and forgettable in fact
if things had never panned out the way
they had
ombre Rouge would have stayed that way
just a place where nothing interesting
ever happened all of that changed of
course when the disappearances started
for anyone who might be too young to
remember them the mid-2000s were a
turbulent time the Iraq war was in full
swing and a nationwide financial crisis
was rapidly approaching but in the midst
of all this Global chaos and instability
the residents of ombre Rouge were soon
to be caught in the thralls of their
very own shared torment at first like
with most bad things it started small
one person went missing an unfortunate
occurrence but not exactly unheard of
sadly these things happened especially
when you live so close to the swamplands
of Louisiana people wander out into the
marsh under the Searing Heat Of The Sun
only to suffer heat stroke collab and
end up buried in the dark dank mud never
to be seen again few of those living in
the town took much notice of the first
disappearance apart from the missing
person's relatives many just Shrugged
off the news as sad as it was most of
the townsfolk were just grateful it
hadn't happened to any of their own
family or friends maybe it was that
ignorance that lack of vigilance or
reaction that meant a second resident
would also be reported missing not long
after the first but this time was
different unlike the previous
disappearance this one had an eyewitness
Clement Donovan known to locals as Clem
had spotted a passerby while taking out
bags of garbage this unassuming
pedestrian was the second disappearance
victim thinking little of the man who
just seemed to be walking home Clem went
back inside a split second later he
heard a scream from outside and rushed
back to his dimly lit porch it was there
that Clem claimed he saw something
retreating towards the nearby Woods
however Clem's wild story of something
not quite human wasn't taken seriously
by local police he even managed to snap
a grainy photo on his clamshell cell
phone but back in 2005 phone cameras
were nowhere near as advanced as they
are today most ombre Rouge locals wrote
Clem off as a crazy old man at best but
worst it made him look like someone who
is trying to exploit or make light of
the disappearances something that
garnered him a lot of dirty looks from
his neighbors that was until a number of
other residents started reporting they
had also witnessed a humanoid creature
it's hard to save any of these
eyewitnesses were genuine and how many
were just people latching on to Clem's
story regardless the disappearances
hadn't stopped and it didn't take long
for an unknown organization to roll into
on play Rouge after hearing the rumors
of a creature sighting a few residents
even the local sheriff's department
thought these Shady Figures were a
division of forensic Specialists here to
Aid in the investigations into the
missing persons the more conspiratorial
folks living in the town had a different
explanation that the newcomers were a
deep state-controlled top-secret
government group there to assess the
possibility that there really was some
kind of monster on the loose not long
after this group had arrived in ombre
Rouge the number of residents going
missing seemed to dwindle on the 18th of
December 2005 they packed up and left
town giving no explanation to the local
police nobody knew if this secretive
Foundation had actually uncovered the
perpetrator responsible for all the
disappearances if there even was any
creature like the rumors said but
whatever had transpired in that
Louisiana swamp Town one thing was clear
the moment the foundation left nobody
else went missing from on play Rouge or
at least not for over a decade before
then however little else of note
happened in OMG Rouge after the initial
Spate of missing persons cases this
apart from a car accident that took
place just under a year after the
various disappearances ended a heavily
injured Man by the name of Simon Hayes
was taken to a local hospital suffering
from a severe concussion Simon had been
involved in a collision with a car on
the 11th of November 2006. the doctors
that examined him determined that Simon
had been left with short-term retrograde
amnesia a condition that affected all
his memories from prior to the accident
it was due to this that he was unable to
recall events that occurred in the years
before he'd sustained his injuries now
what is it that makes a random if
unfortunate car accident victim so
significant well Simon Hayes actually
became the first person in Emperor Rouge
to be declared missing in almost a
decade in 2016 10 years after his
accident at 11 after the original slew
of disappearances Simon vanished when
returning to his hometown in Louisiana
to visit his family naturally Simon
Hayes wouldn't be the last familiar face
to return to the town a repetition of
such similar and strange occurrences as
before also brought the mysterious
Foundation rolling back in little did
the townsfolk know in the year that had
followed the group's original Exodus
from Emperor Rouge they had lost
something on the exact same day Simon
suffered his accident whatever it was
the foundation had left town with had
managed to escape perhaps this was a
purely coincidental occurrence but what
if it wasn't after all road traffic
collisions take place all the time all
over the world but an accident happening
in a town with a history of people going
missing on the exact same day that this
thing escaped captivity maybe there was
a link between the two events at the
very least the foundation seemed to
think so some of the more astute people
living in the swamp side Town noticed
black Armored Transport vehicles moving
into their neighborhoods men in body
armor locking down the whole of ombre
Rouge these didn't seem like local
police they weren't even the National
Guard although they were certainly
heavily armed enough to cause concern
this unit of specially trained
operatives quickly took control of the
entire Township their authority never
questioned by the sheriff's department
the place was small enough isolated by
surrounding swamps and Marshland that
was easy for mobile task force Epsilon 6
to get away with an operation like this
before the people of hombre Rouge had
time to argue the task force had already
begun their investigation the newest
series of disappearances had started in
2016 with Simon Hayes mysteriously
Vanishing and had continued two years
later in 2018 just like the first bait
back in 2005 there were sporadic and
unconfirmed eyewitness accounts of a
creature shaped like a human but
considerably taller almost two meters in
height most Witnesses reported only ever
seeing this local Boogeyman at night
time making it much harder to see in
detail although a few seem to State its
skin was deep red unlike any natural
human skin tone while before residents
of the Louisiana swamp Town had brushed
off stories like this as nothing more
than rumors and urban legends the
foundation seemed pretty receptive to
the idea of some kind of monster on the
loose in the Marshland and after all
they had good reason to believe such an
outlandish story because it was the same
creature that had already escaped from
them in 2006 continuing their
investigation into the link between
Simon Hayes and this creature mobile
task force Epsilon 6 also known by the
code name the village idiots arrived at
Hayes's place of residence kicking the
door down breaching the house they began
a room by room sweep looking for any
clues that would explain why the monster
they'd captured escaped on the same day
as Simon's accident one of the MTF
operatives uncovered something an
envelope stashed in the home Simon had
grown up in he opened it cautiously a
collection of papers that were contained
inside Kane's spilling out there were a
series of simple drawings on paper that
seemed to be more than a few years old
the crudeness of the hand-scralled
pictures and age of the paper seemed to
imply that they had been created by a
child a number of the drawings depicted
the same thing a red-skinned creature
just like the one the townsfolk had
reported seeing with them was a note
written by Simon's mother which read
found these old drawings of yours
thought you might like to see them again
welcome home there was a link an unclear
maybe tangential connection but one that
was growing the more information the
foundation uncovered whatever this being
was a very young Simon Hayes had seen it
while growing up in ample Rouge due to
the short-term retrograde amnesia that
he'd sustained after his accident he
wouldn't have remembered it but perhaps
this thing remembered him did that mean
pair of them might be linked somehow not
just by coincidence but some kind of
connection that allowed the creature to
escape its captivity on the exact day
Simon had his car accident a connection
that had drawn Haze back home to Ampere
Rouge or drawn the Beast to Simon to
kidnap him moving fast MTF Epsilon 6
began to rapidly sweep the remainder of
the Town searching for any further signs
that would lead them to the whereabouts
of either Simon Hayes or this elusive
crimson-skinned Boogeyman they
interviewed residents and chased cold
leads before eventually backing their
target into a corner the foundation's
MTF operatives map the location of every
eyewitness report of the creature using
that information to track it back to a
possible point of origin it was a barn
left abandoned practically falling apart
as it stood in a state of disrepair just
outside the small Louisiana Town under
the cover of Darkness the task force
approached the wooden structure weapons
locked and loaded keeping them trained
on
cautiously moving closer remaining on
high alert the squad activated their
night vision there was a low almost
undetectable sound of movement coming
from within the barn slowly the mtf's
leader pushed open the wooden door and
peeked inside it was there he saw what
they had been looking for the thing that
had escaped the foundation over 10 years
before
scp-3631 a man and his monster the Beast
was just over six feet tall its skin a
bloody shade of crimson just as some of
the eyewitnesses had described it
sported a pair of arms and bipedal legs
giving it a humanoid shape however that
was exactly where its likeness to human
beings ended the creature later
designated as
scp-3631-1 lacked ears eyes or a nose
only a wide gaping maw of sharp teeth
its face was covered in holes that
twitched and puckered like smaller
miniature mouths in actuality it used
these orifices for various senses it
smelled saw and detected sounds through
the holes in its otherwise mostly
featureless face as the members of MTF
Epsilon 6 entered the barn stealthily
making sure not to alert
scp-3631-1 they cited something else
someone else was in the barn with it a
man not a dead victim or another monster
like
scp-3631-1 but an actual living
breathing human man MTF Epsilon 6's
Commander gave his Squad the signal to
engage hearing the sounds of weapons
cocking around it the creature turned
and snarled crawling on all fours like
an animalistic Predator at first it
reared back it wasn't until one member
of the task force approached that
scp-3631-1 retaliated attacking the
foundation operatives in a frenzy
following a prolonged and bloody
exchange MTF Epsilon 6 managed to subdue
the creature and were able to once again
return it to Foundation in captivity but
this time unlike back in 2005 they had
scp-3631-2 as well as the red monster
was prepped for transport a survivor of
the task force noticed something an ID
perhaps a driver's license on the a
man's person the Epsilon 6 operative
picked the card up wiping away smears of
blood with a glove finger enough to
reveal a single familiar name printed on
it Simon Hayes before long just like
last time the foundation rolled back out
of ombre Rouge leaving the Louisiana
townsfolk none the wiser about what had
happened there little did they know the
Red Shadow hanging over their home had
been lifted but it had come at the cost
of a number of disappearances that would
remain unsolved people who would never
be found families forced to go on
without Ever Getting answers when he was
returned to the foundation's labs
scp-3631-2 was sent for extensive
examination given the severity of the
invasive organ transplant seat undergone
it was impossible to tell if he was in
fact Simon the creature had been
regularly replacing the man's internal
organs on a monthly basis whenever they
showed signs of Decay or failing somehow
despite the high risk of blood loss and
infection posed by this crude form of
surgery the subject had remained alive
but he was unable to speak conscious but
showing very limited responses to
stimuli nobody knows why the carnivorous
nocturnal monster
scp-3631-1 took this man captive in the
same vein it is unclear why the creature
felt such a need to protect him going to
such lengths as hunting for replacement
organs from unwilling donors perhaps in
a grisly Twisted way
scp-3631-1 was this man's guardian angel
or maybe more a devil on his shoulder I
wonder is it really possible for
something to be both now go and check
out s scp-096 the Shy Guy and scp-049
the plague doctor for more Tales of
creepy and cruel creatures that you
really don't want to have any close
encounters with